So hopefully we're going to get past
genesis one today.
That's the theory.
So I finished my new book yesterday.
Thank you.
Yes,
that's,
that's taken about three years of
writing.
It's quite a long time to write
something.
So yeah,
I'm done except for the mopping up,
you know,
copy editing and that sort of thing.
So hopefully it's as good as I can make
it.
I don't know if that's any good,
but it's as good as I can make it
anyways.
All right,
so this is the stories that I'm going to
tell you tonight.
I've been thinking about,
well like the ones last week for that
matter for very long period of time,
but I think these even longer and one of
the things that I just do not
understand,
I cannot fathom this.
I cannot understand how there can be so
much information in such tiny little
stories,
especially the story of Cain and Abel.
That story.
Just every time I read it it just
flattens me because it,
it's only like a paragraph long.
There's just nothing to it,
you know,
and I think about it,
I think about it and I think about it
and I think about it.
Every time I think about it,
another layer comes out from underneath
it and then another layer comes out from
underneath it and I can't figure that
out.
Like you know,
the rational approach that I've been
describing to you is predicated on the
idea that these stories have somehow
encapsulated wisdom that we generated
interpersonally on behaviorally and then
an image over very vast stretches of
time and then condensed it into very,
very dense articulated words that are
then further refined by the act of being
remembered and transmitted and
remembered and transmitted,
remembered and transmitted over vast
stretches of time.
And that's a pretty good argument.
I'm willing to.
I'm willing to go with it,
but it's still never ceases to amaze me
how much information such tiny little
passages can can contain.
So we'll,
we'll take that apart today.
I think it's especially true with the
story of Cain and Abel because it works
on the individual level and it works on
the familial level in.
It works.
On the political level and it works at
the level of warfare and it works at the
level of economics and it's.
That's a lot for a little tiny one
paragraph story to cover,
man.
Now you know you could object well with
these stories.
You never know what you're reading into
it and once in the story,
right?
That's part of,
let's call it the postmodern dilemma and
fair enough
and there's really no answer to that
anymore than there is an answer to how
do you know your interpretation of the
world is well,
let's not say correct,
but sufficient.
There's some answer to that.
It's sufficient in if you can act it out
in the world and other people don't
object too much and you don't die and
nature doesn't take a bite out of you
any more often than necessary.
You know,
those are the constraints within which
we live.
So you have some way of determining
whether your interpretation is at least
functionally successful and that's.
And that's not trivial
and I guess you could say the same thing
to the interpretations that might be
laid out on these stories and at the
moment that's probably good enough.
Hopefully you find the interpretations
functionally significant at multiple
levels and I also think the chance of
managing that by chance is very,
very small,
you know,
to to be able to pull off an
interpretation of a story that works at
multiple levels simultaneously.
You think with each level that it
applies,
the chances that you've stumbled across
something by chance have to be
decreasing right now that there's a
technical term for that.
In psychology it's called something like
multi-method multi trait.
A method of determining whether or not
something is accurate and the idea is
the more ways that you can measure it
and get the same result,
the more confident you can be.
That you're not just deluding yourself
with your a priori hypothesis.
You know,
that there's actually something out
there.
So I guess that's another part of this
method is that.
And it's also a method that I use in my,
in my speaking,
I think I don't try to tell people
anything that isn't personally relevant
because you should know why you are
being taught something,
right,
you should know what the fact is good
for,
and then it should be good for you
personally,
at least in some sense.
And then if you act it out in the world,
it should be good for your family and
maybe should have some significance for
the broader community.
I mean,
I think that's what meaning means.
And I don't really see the utility in
being taught things that aren't
meaningful facts that aren't meaningful
because there's an infinite number of
facts and there's no way you're going to
remember all of them.
They have to be.
They have to have the aspect of tools
essentially.
Something like that.
Because we are a tool using creatures
while these these stories have that
aspect is as far as I can tell,
there's nothing.
There's no doubt about that.
So here's the stories in genesis two
very famous stories.
Obviously,
virtually everybody who's even vaguely
versed in western,
roughly speaking,
western Western culture knows these
stories and that's something that's
interesting too,
that stories can be so foundational that
everybody shares them.
I mean you can say the same thing about
a fairly large handful of fairytales as
well,
or you could at least until recently,
but the fact that stories are
foundational,
I think also means that they have to be
given a kind of,
well,
even if you don't give them any respect,
you have to at least treat them as
curiosities.
Why those stories and why did they stick
around and why does everybody know them
and it's not self evident by any stretch
of the imagination and you can use
explanations,
can use the Freudian explanation.
Freud sort of thought that the Judaeo
Christian was predicated on the idea
that the figure of the father,
the familial father,
was expanded up into cosmic dimension so
that mankind existed in the same
relationship to the cosmic father.
Let's say that an infant or a small
child existed in relationship to his or
her own father and that's a reasonable
critique.
I would say to some degree,
but it does,
and and,
and this was purposeful.
It does imply more than imply in Freud's
case that people who adopt a religious
belief that has a persona figure as at
its apex are essentially acting out the
role of dependent children and you know,
I thought about that critique for a long
time and believe me,
that's been a powerful critique.
One of the best books I ever read called
the denial of death by Ernest Becker I
think took that line of argumentation.
It developed it as well as any,
any book I've ever seen argue it back or
tried to bring closure to Freudian
psychoanalysis on religion and he did a
pretty wicked job of it.
Like I think the book is seriously
flawed and wrong,
but it's really a great book.
Like some books are well,
some books are wrong and really good
ways,
right?
They make a powerful,
powerful argument.
They really take it to its extreme.
I think Becker missed the point and he
missed it in the same way that Freud,
Mrs [inaudible] point and Becker who
wrote this book on the psychology,
the psychoanalysis of religion,
never referred to except very briefly in
the introduction and I think that was a
major mistake,
but becker took the argument that the
hypothesis of God is nothing but an
attempt by human beings to recreate a
infant infantile state of dependency and
to be able to rely on an all knowing
father and to thereby recovered the
comfort perhaps that we experienced when
we were young and had a hypothetically
all knowing father for those of us who
were lucky to have someone who rigged
vaguely resembled death,
but the more I thought about that,
the more that that struck me as quite
implausible across time.
Charles Taylor,
I think it was Charles Taylor wrote an
interesting book called the,
I think it was called the origins of the
modern self.
He's a philosopher.
I wouldn't necessarily call him a friend
of classic religion,
but it doesn't matter.
He made a very interesting point about
Christianity in particular.
He said,
well,
if you're going to invent a religion
that offered you nothing but infant tile
comfort,
why in the world would you bother
conceptualizing hell?
That just seems like an unnecessary
detail to add to the whole story,
right?
If it's.
If it's all about comfort,
why would you hypothesize that the
consequence of of serious error was
eternal torment?
That doesn't really sound very.
It isn't the sort of thing that that is
likely to make you feel comfortable.
James Joyce,
when he wrote about that city,
had terrible nightmares when he was a
child because of the Hellfire to
sermons.
The jesuits used to spout,
spew forth let's say,
and he wrote down what he remembered of
them and they were pretty hair raising.
I think in James Joyce's book,
I think it was portrait of the artist as
a young man,
man.
He talked about the jesuits telling them
and telling them that hell was a like a
prison with walls that were seven miles
thick that was always in darkness and
consumed by fire and that the people who
are trapped there were continually burnt
by this dark fire that gave New Light.
Which also simultaneously rejuvenated
their flesh so that it could be burned
off eternally in case you were wondering
how it was going to be burned off
eternally.
That's apparently the process.
It's not easy for me to see that as an
infant tile wish fulfillment.
I'm afraid now you could.
Well you could be a cynic about it.
And Elaine pagels who who wrote a book
on the devil was cynical about it in
this manner.
She thought that the Christians so to
speak,
invented hell as a place to put their
enemies and you know.
Yeah,
fair enough.
But no,
that's not accurate really.
Although it's convenient to have a place
to put your enemies.
Charles Taylor did point out,
for example,
that the modern terror of loss of self,
let's say the existential loss of self
and loss of meaning was perhaps roughly
paralleled by the medieval terror of
hell.
You know,
in terms of existential intensity.
And so it wasn't.
Hell wasn't merely a place where those
people that you didn't care for,
it would end up.
It was the place where you were going to
go if you didn't walk the line properly.
And so I don't think Freud's Freud's
critique really holds water in the final
analysis and then marks his critique,
of course,
was that religion was the opiate of the
masses and he made an argument that was
similar to Freud's,
although somewhat earlier and made the
based upon the presupposition that
religious police were stories told to
the gullible masses in order to keep
them pacified and happy.
Well they're corporate overlords for
lack of a better purpose,
continue to exploit them and,
and,
and weaken them.
And you know,
I find that I find the critique of human
institutions as driven entirely by power
very,
let's say questionable to say the least.
And of course every human institution is
corrupted by,
corrupted his corrupt by,
for one reason or another.
And it's also corrupt specifically by
such things as deception and arrogance
and the demand for unearned power.
And the same thing of course can be
applied to religious systems,
but that doesn't mean that they are in
some special way characteristic of those
faults.
And maybe you think they are and you
know,
maybe you could make a case for it,
but it's not primary.
I think that's how you say that,
evident that that is.
That also is a particularly useful
criticism.
I don't buy it.
I think there's.
I think that's far too cynical.
I think that the people who wrote these
stories,
first of all,
what are you going to do?
You're going to read it.
You're going to run a bloody conspiracy
for 3000 years successfully.
It's like,
good luck with that.
Can't run a conspiracy for 15 minutes
without somebody ratting you out.
You know it's,
it's impossible.
So whatever's at the basis of the
construction,
not only of these stories,
but of the dogmatic structures that
emerged from them,
I think that it's a terrible mistake to
reduce them to unit dimensional
explanations.
In fact,
I generally think that reducing any
complex human behavior to unidimensional
explanation is often a sign of a
seriously limited thinker.
And you know,
I,
I say that with some caution because
Freud did do that with religion at least
to some degree in Freud was a serious
thinker and marks,
I suppose was a serious thinker too,
even though.
Well yeah,
if he's someone you just,
if you have any sense marks,
just leaves you speechless.
So,
so anyway,
so that's all to say that I don't think
there's any simple explanation for how
these stories have the power that they
have.
I really don't.
I don't think you can reduce it to
political conspiracy,
that's for sure.
I don't think you can reduce it to
psychological infantile ism.
I think you can make a case like I have
that they are repositories of the
collective wisdom of the human race.
I had an interesting letter this week
from someone.
I get a lot of interesting letters.
I think I'm going to make an archive out
of them and put them on the web at some
point with people's permission
obviously.
Um,
and he said that he'd been following my
lectures and noted that I'd been making
what you might describe as a quasi
biological or evolutionary case for,
for the emergence of the information
that the stories contained.
And he said,
well,
how do you know that someone from a
different religious tradition or
speaking of a different religious
tradition couldn't do exactly the same
thing?
And I thought,
well,
first of all,
to some degree they could because there
is overlap.
Like I've talked to you a little bit
about Dallas,
for example,
in the,
in the Dallas view of,
of being as,
you know,
the eternal balance between chaos and
order.
One thing I didn't tell you,
I don't think about that,
and I,
I don't know if you know this,
but there's a neuropsychologist named
Elkanah and Goldberg who is a student of
Alexander Luria.
Luria was,
I think the greatest neuro psychologist
of the 20th century.
He was a Russian and he was one of the
first people to really determine,
in large part the function of the
frontal Cortex,
which was quite a mystery for a very
long period of time.
And Goldberg,
you know,
you know how we have two hemispheres,
right?
We have a left hemisphere and right
hemisphere.
And people often think of the left for
right handed people,
right handed males more particularly
because women are more neurologically
diffuse a.
it's one of the things that makes it
more robust to head injury,
for example.
Um,
and,
and maybe men are less diffused and
somewhat more specialized,
which makes them a bit more specialized,
but a little more subject to damage.
Anyways,
we have two hemispheres left and the
right and no one exactly knows why and
we know that they housed quasi
independent consciousnesses because if
you divide the Corpus callosum that,
that unites them,
which was done to in cases of
intractable epilepsy,
for example,
that each hemisphere is capable of
developing its own consciousness to some
degree.
The right generally nonverbal and the
left verbal.
And so there has been this idea that the
left is a verbal hemisphere and the
right is a nonverbal hemisphere,
but that can't be right because of
course animals don't talk and they have
a bifurcated hemisphere.
So if it's right,
it's not causally right.
Right now,
Goldberg hypothesized instead that the
hemispheres we're,
we're a specialized for route and
ization and non routinized or for
novelty and familiarity or for chaos and
order.
And so that's pretty damn cool.
When I ran across that,
I also thought about that as a,
as a signal of,
of what would you call it,
multi-method multi trait,
construct validation because I'd never
thought of the hemispheres is operating
that way and Goldberg came up with this
in a in a historical pathway that was
entirely independent from any
mythologically inspired thinking,
completely independent fact.
It was motivated more by materialist
Russian neuro-psychology,
which was materialist for political
reasons and also for scientific reasons,
but the idea is that we have one
hemisphere that reacts very rapidly to
things we don't know and it's more
imaginative and diffuse and it,
and it's associated more with negative
emotion because negative emotion is what
you should feel immediately when you
encounter something you don't understand
because it's a form of thinking,
right?
Negative emotion.
It's like I'm somewhere where things
aren't what they should be,
right hemisphere does.
That generates images very rapidly to
help you figure out what might be there,
and then the left hemisphere takes that
and develops it into something that's
more articulated and an algorithmic and
fully understood.
And so then there's this dynamic balance
between the right and the left
hemisphere where the left tries to
impose order on the world that's
Ramachandran who is a neurologist and in
California,
very famous neuro neuro neuro
neurologist who also developed a theory
light Goldberg's who said that the left
hemisphere imposes routinized order on
the world and the right hemisphere
generates novelty and,
and uh,
and reacts to novelty and generates
novel hypotheses.
And he thought,
and there is some good evidence for
this.
That's what happened.
What's happening during the dream is
that information has moved from the
right hemisphere to the left hemisphere
in small doses basically.
So that the novel revelations of the
Right Hemisphere don't demolish the
algorithmic structures that the left
hemisphere has so carefully put
together.
So,
and I like that theory too because it
also does help justify the hypothesis
that I been laying out for you,
which is that,
you know,
there's part of us that extends
ourselves out into the world and try to
understand what we don't know and that
that part extends itself out with
behavior and also with emotion and also
image.
And then maybe with poetry and then
maybe with storytelling,
and then as that develops,
then we develop more and more
articulated representations of that
emergent knowledge and so you can map
that quite nicely onto the neurologists
and the neuropsychologist's presumption
about what constitutes the reason for
the hemispheric differentiation.
But the other thing that's so cool about
the hemispheric differentiation argument
as far as I'm concerned,
and this is really this is worth
thinking about man,
because it's a real.
It's a real.
There's a word that ned ned flanders
uses for that Norgen scratcher.
I think it's something like that.
Anyways.
You know,
we do make the assumption that what it
is that we are biologically adapted to
his reality,
right?
It's actually an axiomatic definition if
you're a Darwinian,
because nature is what?
Select by definition.
That's what nature is.
It's what select and if the nature that
selects is forced upon you a dual
hemispheric structure,
because half of you has to deal with the
chaos in half,
half of you has to deal with order.
Then you can make a pretty damn strong
influential case that the world is made
out of chaos.
And order,
and that's really something to,
that's really something to think about
mountain,
you know,
so you can think about that for a while
if you want.
So anyways,
for whatever reason,
there is a lot packed into these
stories.
And so let's investigate a couple more
of them.
We'll start with this story of Adam and
eve.
Now you may remember that the Bible is a
series of books.
Bible actually means something akin to
library.
And these books are written by all sorts
of different people and groups of people
and groups of editors and groups of
people who edited over and over across
the very,
very large periods of time.
So they are authored by no one and many
at the same time.
Um,
the,
there was a tradition for a long time
that the earliest books were written by
Moses,
but that,
that's probably not technically correct
even though it might be dramatically
correct,
let's say,
or correct in the way that a fairytale
is correct.
And I'm,
I'm not trying to put down fairy tales
by saying that there's a number of
authors in the way the authors have been
identified tentatively is by certain
stylistic commonalities across the
different stories,
different uses of words like the words
for God,
different poetic styles,
different topics and so forth,
and people have been working for
probably 200 years roughly that to try
to sort out who wrote what and how that
was all cobbled together,
but it doesn't really matter for our
purposes.
What matters is that it's an aggregation
of collected narrative traditions and
maybe you could say it's an aggregation
of collective narrative wisdom.
We don't have to go that far,
but we can at least say it's aggregated
narrative traditions and that there was
some reason that those traditions and
all the others were kept in that.
There were some reasons complex though
they may have been why they were
sequenced in the order that they were
sequenced.
Because one of the things that's really
remarkable about the Bible as an as a
document is that it actually has a plot.
And that's really something.
I mean,
it's,
it's sprawling and it goes many places,
but the fact that something's been
cobbled together over several thousand
years,
maybe 4,000
maybe longer than that,
if you include the oral traditions that
preceded it and god only knows how old
those are,
that that collective imagination part of
the human collective imagination has
cobbled together a library with a plot
and like I see the Bible as an attempt.
A collective attempt by humanity is
solve the deepest problems that we have
and I think those problems are the
problems of pro primary.
That the problem of self consciousness.
The fact that not only do we are,
we are mortal and that we die,
but we know it.
And that's the unique.
That's the unique predicament of human
beings and it makes all the difference.
And I think that's laid out in Adam and
eve in the story of Adam and eve.
I think the reason that that makes us
unique and is laid out in that story,
and interestingly,
I really realized this only after I was
doing the last three lectures.
So the Bible presents a cataclysmic.
A cataclysm at the beginning of the of
time,
which is the emergence of self
consciousness and human beings,
which puts a rift into the structure of
being.
That's the right way to think about it
and that's really given cosmic
significance.
Now you can dispense with that and say,
well,
nothing that happens to human beings as
of cosmic significance because we're
these short lived,
you know,
mold like entities that are like cancers
on this tiny little planet that's
rotating out in the middle of nowhere on
the edge of some unknown galaxy in the
middle of infinite space and nothing
that happens to us matters and it's fine
and you like,
you can walk down that road if you want.
I wouldn't recommend it.
I mean,
and that's part of the reason I think
that for all intents and purposes it's
untrue.
You know,
it isn't,
it isn't a road you can walk down and
live well.
In fact,
I think if you really walk down that
road and you really take it seriously,
you end up not living at all.
So it's certainly very reminiscent.
I mean,
I've talked to lots of people are
suicidal and seriously suicidal and you
know,
the kind of conclusions that they draw
about the utility of life prior to
wishing for its cessation are very much
like the kind of conclusions that you
draw.
If you walk down that particular line of
reasoning long enough,
if you're interested in that,
you could read Tolstoy's confession,
Leo Tolstoy's confession.
It's a very short book.
It's so,
it's a killer man.
It's,
it's a powerful book.
Very,
very short.
And tolstoy describes his obsession with
suicide when he was at the height of his
fame,
most well known author in the world,
you know,
huge family,
international fame,
wealth beyond anyone's imagining at that
time,
um,
influential,
admired,
he had everything that you could
possibly imagine that everyone could
have.
And for years he was afraid to go out
into his barn with a rope or a gun
because he thought he'd either hang
himself or shoot himself.
And he did get out of that.
He and he describes why that happened
and where he went,
when that happened.
And so if you're interested in that,
that that's a very good book,
but
so the biblical stories and starting
with Adam and eve,
they present a different story.
They present the emergence of self
consciousness in human beings as
cosmically cataclysmic event,
and you could say,
well,
what do we have to do with the cosmos?
And the answer to that is it depends on
what you think consciousness has to do
with the cosmos and perhaps that's
nothing and perhaps it's everything.
I'm going to go with everything because
that's how it looks to me.
Now,
of course,
anyone who wishes to as welcome to
disagree,
but if you believe that consciousness is
a force of cosmic significance,
which which,
which,
which being itself is dependent on in
any real sense,
at least in any experiential sense,
that it's not unreasonable to assume
that radical restructurings of
consciousness can worthy be granted some
kind of cosmic or metaphysical
significance and even if it's not true
from outside the human perspective,
whatever that might be,
it's bloody well true from within the
human perspective.
That's for sure.
And so that's the.
That's the initial event in some sense,
after the creation is the cataclysmic
fall and then the entire rest of the
Bible is an attempt to figure out what
the hell to do about that and everything
in it is is,
and so you could say for example,
in the earliest in in,
in the old testament stories,
what seems to happen is that the state
of Israel is is founded and it rises and
falls and rises and falls,
and so there's this experimentation for
centuries,
millennia,
even with the idea that the way that you
protect yourself against the tragic
consequences of self consciousness is by
organizing yourself into a state,
but then what happens is the state
itself begins to reveal its pathologies
and as those pathologies mount,
the state becomes unstable and collapses
and then it
rises back up and becomes unstable and
collapses and then it rises back up
after it does this a number of times.
This is primarily from northrop prize
interpretations.
People start wondering if there's not
something wrong with the idea that the
state itself is.
This is the,
is the pathway is the place of
redemption.
That there's something wrong with that
idea,
and so then I think on the heels of that
comes the Christian revolution with its
hypothesis that it's not the state
that's,
that's the place of salvation.
It's the individual psyche and then
there's,
there's a,
an ethic that goes along with that too,
which is quite interesting.
So the ethic of redemption after the
state experiment fails,
let's say is that it's,
it's the,
it's within the individual that
redemption can be manifested,
let's say,
and even in so far as the state is
concerned because the state's proper
functioning is dependent on the proper
functioning of the individual rather
than the reverse.
Most fundamentally and that the proper
motive,
individual being that's redemptive is
truth and truth is the antidote to this
suffering.
That's that emerges with the fall of man
in the story of Adam and eve.
And then that relates back to the
chapters that we've already talked about
because there's this insistence in
genesis one that it's the word in the
form of the of truth that generates
order out of chaos.
But even more importantly,
and this is something I like I said,
I most clearly realized just doing these
lectures for the last three weeks,
is God continues to say as he speaks,
order into being with truth,
that the being he speaks into being is
good and so there's this insistence that
the being that spoke into being through
truth is good and so there's a hint
there.
It's so interesting.
There's a hint there,
right at the beginning of the story that
that the state of being that Adam and
eve inhabited before they fail,
before they became self consciousness
conscious in so far as they were made in
the image of God and acting out the
truth,
that the being itself was properly
balanced and it takes the entire Bible
to rediscover that which is a,
which is a journey back to the
beginning.
Right?
And that that's a classic theme.
It's a classic mythological theme that
the wise person is the person who finds
what they lost in childhood and regains
it.
Right?
So that's A.
I think that's a Jewish idea that Zadie,
if I remember correctly,
it was a messiah figure,
is the person who finds what he lost in
childhood and regains it to this idea of
this return to the beginning,
except that the return is you don't fall
backwards into childhood and
unconsciousness.
You returned voluntarily to the state of
childhood,
well awake and then determined to
participate through truth in the
manifestation of proper being.
Now you know,
I'm a psychologist and I've taught
personality theory for a very long time
and I know a personality theories that
profound personality theories pretty
well and I'm reasonably well versed in
philosophy,
although not as well versed as I should
be,
but I can tell you in all the things
I've ever read or encountered or thought
about,
I have never once found an idea that
matches that in terms of profundity but
not only profundity also in
believability.
Because the other thing I see as a
clinician,
and I think this is very characteristic
of clinical experience and also very
much described explicitly by the great
clinicians,
is that what cures in therapy is truth.
That's the curative.
Now there's exposure to the things
you're afraid of and avoiding as well,
but I would say that's a form of enacted
truth because if you know there's
something you should do by your own set
of rules and you're avoiding it,
then you're enacting a lot.
You know you're not telling one,
but you're acting out.
It's the same damn thing.
So if I can get you to face what it is
that you're confronting that you know
you shouldn't be avoiding,
then what's happening is that we're both
partaking in the process of attempting
to act out your deepest truth and what
happens is that that improves people's
lives and it improves them radically and
the evidence for the clinical evidence
for that is overwhelming.
We know that if you expose people to the
things they're afraid of but that
they're avoiding,
they get better and you have to do it
carefully and cautiously and with their
own participation and all of that,
but of all the things that clinicians
have established that's credible,
that's number one,
and that's nested inside this deeper
realization that the clinical experience
is redemptive,
let's say,
because it is designed to address
suffering in so far as the people who
are engaged in the process are both
telling each other the truth and then
you think,
well obviously,
because if you have some problems and
you come to talk to me about them,
well first of all just by coming to talk
to me about them.
You've admitted that they exist.
Man.
That's a pretty good start.
And second,
well if you tell me about them,
then we know what they are and then if
we know what they are,
we can maybe start to lay out some
solutions and then you can go act out
the solution to see if they work.
But if you don't admit they're there and
you won't tell me what they are.
And I don't,
and I'm like posturing and,
and,
and acting egotistically and taking the
upper hand in all of that in our
discussions.
Well,
how the hell is that going to work?
You know,
it might be comfortable moment to moment
while we stay encapsulated in our
delusion,
but it's not going to work.
So a lot of that seems to think it
through.
It seems pretty self evident.
And you know,
Freud thought that repression was at the
heart of much mental suffering.
The difference between repression and
deception is a matter of degree and
that's all.
It's technical.
It's a technical differentiation.
And Alfred Adler who was one of Freud's
greatest associates,
let's say,
and much under appreciated,
I would say he thought that people got
into problems because they started to
act out a life lie.
That's what he called it,
a life lie that's worth looking up
because Adler,
although not as charismatic as Freud,
was very practical and,
and,
and really foreshadowed a lot of later
developments in cybernetic theory.
And of course young believed that you
could bypass psychotherapy entirely by
merely making a proper moral effort in
your own life.
And Carl Rogers believed that it was
honest communication mediated through
dialogue that had redemptive
consequences and the behaviors believe
that you do a careful micro analysis of
the problems that are laid before you
would help introduce people to what
they're avoiding.
It's like all of those things to me are
just secular variations of the notion
that truth will set you free
essentially.
So,
so you know,
it's a pretty powerful story and a,
a,
it's not that easy to dispense with.
And B,
the other thing is you dispense with it
at your peril.
Because what I have seen as well as
that,
the people that I've seen have been
really hurt,
have been hurt mostly by deceit.
And that's also worth thinking about
that you know,
you get walloped by life.
There's no doubt about that.
Absolutely no doubt about that.
But I thought for a long time that maybe
maybe,
maybe people can hang handle earthquakes
and cancer and even death meaning,
but they can't handle betrayal and they
can't handle deception.
It can't handle having the rug pulled
out from underneath and by people that
they love and trust.
Not just does them in,
you know,
it,
it makes them ill,
but it does where it hurts the
psychophysiological,
it damages them,
but more than that,
it makes them cynical and bitter and
vicious and resentful,
and then they also start to act all that
out in the world and that makes it
worse.
So,
so you know,
the story starts.
God uses the spoken truth to create
being that is good and then the
cataclysm occurs and then human beings
spend untold millennia trying to sort
out exactly what to do about the fact
that they've become self conscious and
you know by the way we have right,
we are in fact self conscious.
No other animal has that distinction.
Now you'll read that chimpanzees can,
for example,
if you put lipstick on a chimpanzee,
just kind of a strange thing to do.
Well I won't pursue that any further,
but the chimpanzee chimpanzee will wipe
off the lipstick if you show it a
mirror.
And Dolphin seemed to be able to
recognize themselves in mirrors.
And there is.
So there is the glimmerings of self
conscious recognition in other animals.
But to put that in the same conceptual
category as human self consciousness is
into my way of thinking.
It's,
it's,
well,
it's uninformed to say the least,
but I also think that it's motivated.
It's motivated by a kind of anti
humanistic underlying an underlying
motivation.
Because our self consciousness is so
incredibly developed compared to that,
that they're hardly in the St conceptual
universe.
It's.
It's like comparing the.
The alarm cries of vervet monkeys when
they see a Predator to the language of
human,
it's like,
yeah,
yeah.
There's some similarities,
man.
Their utterances,
they're utterances with meaning,
but they're not language and the self
consciousness of animals is protos self
consciousness and it's only there and a
very small number of animals.
And if it's nothing like ours,
they're not aware of the future like we
are.
They're not aware of their boundaries in
space and time.
And that's the critical thing.
And most particularly time human beings
discovered time and when we discovered
time,
we discovered the end of each of our
being and that made all the difference.
And that's what the story of Adam and
Eve is about.
So genesis one is derived from the
priestly source where God is known as a
low him or El Shaddai,
and there's God in the singular and the
gods in the plural,
and I suppose that's because it seems
that if you analyze the history of the
development of monotheistic ideas,
that monotheism emerges out of a
plurality of gods and as I mentioned,
I think it's because the gods represent
fundamental forces at minimum and those
fundamental forces have to be
hierarchically organized for some with
something absolutely at the top because
otherwise they do nothing but war.
Right?
You have to organize your values
hierarchically or you stay confused and
that's true.
If you're an individual in it.
It's true.
If your estate,
if you don't know what the next thing
you should do is then there's 50 things
you should do and then how are you going
to do any of them?
You can't.
You have to prioritize.
Something has to be above.
Something else has to be arranged in a
hierarchy for it not to be chaotic,
and so there's some principal at the top
of the hierarchy and maybe the
organization of the gods over time,
that's the battle of gods that Murcia
Eliana talked about.
And if you're interested in that,
you could read a history of religious
ideas,
which I would really recommend it to.
Three volume book.
Um,
it's actually quite as straightforward
read as far as these things go.
And Eliana does a very nice job of
describing how and even why polytheism,
Ken's towards monotheism,
even in polytheistic cultures,
there's a strong tendency for the gods
to organize themselves in a hierarchy
with one God at the top in a,
in a monotheistic culture,
in some,
in some sense,
all the other gods just disappear across
time and there's nothing left,
but the top God.
But even in a polytheistic society,
there's a hierarchy of power among the
gods.
The first story is newer than the second
one.
So the story I'm going to tell you today
is actually older than the one I already
told you,
even though their order was flipped by
the redactor,
who's the hypothetical person or persons
who edited these stories together and we
don't know exactly why he or the
committee or what,
I suspect it was a single person,
but who knows?
We don't know why the stories were
edited together in the order that they
were edit together,
but we could infer,
I mean they were added together in that
order because the editor thought they
made sense that way because that's what
an editor does,
right?
An editor tends to take diverse ideas
and then to organize them in some manner
that makes.
And part of the manner that makes sense
is that you can tell them to people and
the people stay interested and you can
tell them to people and people remember
them.
That's one of the ways you can tell if
you've got an argument,
right,
because it's communicable and
understandable and memorable.
And so he,
this person was let's say,
motivated by intuition to organize the
stories in this particular manner.
So the second the yard was strand
contains the stories,
the classic stories in the pentitude
that's five books,
genesis,
exodus,
leviticus,
numbers,
and Deuteronomy,
which we'll try to get through perhaps
in these 12 lectures was,
we'll see how that goes.
It's strongly on through poor morphic.
So the God in the West account is,
for all intents and purposes,
a sort of metta person.
Um,
and I dealt with that a little bit last
week because people tend to,
you know,
think of that as unsophisticated,
but when you think that the mind that
the ground of consciousness is the most
complex thing that we know of,
then it's not so unsophisticated to
assume that the most complex thing that
there might be is like that,
or it's at least it's as good as we can
do with our imaginations.
And so I don't think it's so,
it's so a,
it's so unsophisticated.
It's also the case,
and this is practically speaking,
is that it is not at all unreasonable to
think of God the father as the spirit
that arises from the crowd that exists
into the future.
Right?
And that's,
we talked about that in relationship to
the idea of sacrifice at least a little
bit more,
or we're going to make sacrifices in the
present so that the future is happy with
you.
And the question is,
what is that future that would be happy
with you?
And answer to that is it's the spirit of
humanity.
That's who you're negotiating with
because you make the assumption that if
you forgo impulsive pleasure and get
your medical degree,
that when you're done in 10 years and
you're a physician,
humanity as such will honor your
sacrifice and commitment and open the
doors to you.
Right?
So you're treating the future as if it's
a single being and you're also treating
it as if it's some something like a
compassionate judge.
You're acting that out and maybe we had
to imagine God in that form before we
could understand.
Once we started to understand that there
was a future,
perhaps we had to imagine God in that
form in order to concretize something
that we could bargain with so that we
could figure out how to use sacrifice to
figure out how to guide ourselves into
the future because as sacrifice is a
contract with the future,
but it's not a contract with any
particular person,
it's.
It's a contract with the spirit of
humanity as such.
It's something like that,
and so when you think about it that way,
that should make you faint with
amazement because that is such a bloody
amazing idea to come up with that idea
that you can bargain with the future.
That is some idea,
man.
That's,
that's like the major idea of human,
of humankind.
We suffer.
What do we do about it?
We figured out how to bargain with the
future and we minimize suffering in that
manner.
It's like no other animal does that
either.
You know,
like the lions,
they just eat everything.
I think a wolf can eat 40 pounds of meat
in a single city.
Right?
It's like there's some meat,
eat it.
It's like not like save some mammoth for
tomorrow.
That's a.
that's not a wolf thing,
man.
That's a human thing and that might mean
you have to be hungry today or maybe
you're a farmer,
you know,
several thousand years ago,
6,000
years ago or so,
what agriculture first got going and
you're starving to death waiting for the
spring planting and you think we bill it
bloody well better not eat those seeds.
Right,
and that's really something to be able
to control yourself,
to make the future real,
to put off what you could use today and
not just in some impulsive manner,
man,
maybe your kids are starving to death.
You think we are not touching the seeds
that we need for the future and for
human beings to have discovered that and
then to also have figured out that we
could bargain with the future.
It's like,
man,
that's something and I think that that.
I think that the stories that are laid
out in this book actually describe at
least in part the process by which that
occurred.
They always stories begin with genesis
two,
four.
This is the account of the heavens and
the earth when,
so there's two real creation stories at
the beginning,
the newer one,
which is the first one,
and the older one,
which is the second one,
and the older one begins in chapter two
and that's the story that we're going
to,
that we're getting into now.
Adam and eve are in that Cain and Abel.
Noah,
the Tower of Babel in the [inaudible]
strand exodus numbers along,
and there's some of the priestly version
in there too,
as well as the 10 commandments.
Well,
there's some lovely representations of
of Paradise.
This is a garden of earthly delights.
What's his name?
Say That Bosch?
Yes.
Hieronymus Bosch.
He has that crazy.
I mean if you.
How he didn't get burnt at the stake is
absolutely beyond me.
I mean,
you know,
some of you know about Salvador Dali,
I suppose most of you do.
I mean delis a piker compared to
Hieronymus Bosch.
Man,
you could spend,
because there's three pieces of this
particular painting,
you could spend a very bizarre and
surreal month looking at that painting.
I don't know what it was with Bosch,
but he was some sort of creature that
only popped up once and probably for the
best.
And so there's been very many
representations of paradise.
I mean,
God only knows what that is.
It's like I could probably guess,
but I won't.
And then look,
I mean that's,
that's,
that's the lion lying down with the
lamb.
Right?
So that's this idea that's maybe
projected back in time that there was a
time or maybe will be a time when,
when the,
when the horrors of life are no longer
necessary for life itself to exist.
Right?
And the horrors of life or of course
that everything eats everything else and
that everything dies and that
everything's born and the whole bloody
places a charnel house and it's,
it's a catastrophe beginning to end.
And this is the vision of it being.
Other than that.
And you know,
there was a strong idea.
This was also in implicit in the
alchemical ideas.
And I think it's also implicit in the
scientific revolution that human beings
can interact with reality in such a way
so that the tragic and evil elements of
it can be mitigated and so that we can
move somewhat closer to a state that
might be characterized well,
that's obviously images stick,
but it might be characterized by
something like that where we have the
benefits of actual existence without all
of the catastrophe that seems to go
along with it.
And Carl Young,
when he wrote about the emergence of
Alchemy or the emergence of science from
Alchemy,
he thought of science as being motivated
by a dream because for you dream was the
dream was the manifestation of the
instincts.
That was the boundary between the
instincts and thinking.
He said,
well,
sciences nested inside a dream,
and the dream is that if we investigated
the structures of material reality with
sufficient attention and truth,
that we could then learn enough about
material reality to alleviate suffering,
right?
To produce the philosopher's stone,
to make everybody wealthy,
to make everybody healthy,
to make everyone live as long as they
wanted to live for perhaps forever.
That that's the goal,
to alleviate the catastrophe of
existence and that that idea,
the idea that mysteries,
the solution to the mysteries of life
that might enable us to develop such a
substance or let's say a multitude of
substances provided the motive force for
the development of science and young
trace,
that the development of that mode of
force really over a thousand years and
if you're interested in reading his
books on Alchemy,
which are extraordinarily difficult and
that's really saying something about
young because all of his books are
difficult and then the books on Alchemy,
they kind of take a quantum leap.
That's actually a very small leap
choice.
Wouldn't say that they take a massive
leap into a whole different dimension of
complexity,
but that's what he was trying to get at.
He went back into the ELC chemical texts
and interpreted them as if they were the
dream on which science was founded and
Newton was an outcome is by the way,
I mean have hypotheses are certainly
well supported by the historical facts.
Science did emerge out of alchemy.
The question is what were the alchemists
up to?
And they were trying to produce the
philosopher's stone,
and that was the universal medica meant
for mankind's pathology.
Young felt at what had happened was
that,
you know,
Christianity had promised that the
cessation of suffering promised it for a
thousand years and yet suffering went on
unabated.
And at the same times Christianity,
he had attempted to really put emphasis
on spiritual development,
let's say at the expensive material
development,
right?
Thinking of material development as
something akin to a sin,
trying to get a control of impulsivity
and,
and all the things that went along with
a two embodied existence.
There was a reason for it,
but that by about a thousand add the
European mind,
somewhat educated by that point,
somewhat able to concentrate on a single
point perhaps because of a very long
history of intense religious training
turned its dream to the unexplored
material world.
And thought,
well,
you know,
the spiritual redemption that we've been
seeking didn't appear to produce the
result that was promised or intended.
And so maybe there's another place that
we should look.
And that was in the damned material
world,
right?
Which,
which,
which was supposed to be at least
according to some elements of classic
thinking,
nothing about the creation of the devil.
So,
but the three point I'm making is that,
you know,
it's very difficult to underestimate the
amount of human motivation that's
embedded in the attempt to alleviate
suffering,
to eradicate disease,
to help people live a healthy,
healthy life and will,
that's the disease obviously,
but to live a long life as well and to
make things as peaceful as possible.
I mean you can be cynical about people
in,
you can talk about them as motivated by
power and being corrupt and all of those
things and all of those things are true,
but you shouldn't throw away the baby
with the bathwater because we have been
striving for a very long time to set
things right.
And we've done to actually not too bad
at job of it for half starving crazy
insect written chimpanzees with
lifespans of 50 to 70 years.
So,
you know,
we could deserve a bit of sympathy for
our position as far as I'm concerned.
So
some other representations.
This one I liked the one on the left.
That's paradise.
Paradise is a walled garden and that's
what paradise means.
It's paradise that was,
which is,
I don't remember the language.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's associated with Persian parodies.
That means walled garden.
And why a walled garden?
Well,
it goes back to the chaos order idea.
So this is where God puts man in woman
after the creation in a walled garden
wall.
The Wall is culture in order and the
garden is nature.
And the idea is the proper huet and
habitat is nature and culture in
balance.
And while we like gardens,
well why?
Because well,
they're not completely covered with
weeds and mosquitoes and black flies,
right?
So they're,
they're civilized a little bit,
but still within that civilization
nature,
it's more benevolent.
Guys is encouraged to flourish and
people find that rejuvenating.
And so the idea that paradise,
the proper habitat of a human being is
a,
is a walled garden is a good one and
it's walled because while you want to
keep things out,
right?
I mean raccoons for example,
you want,
you want to keep those things out,
man,
even though it's impossible.
And you know,
you don't,
you don't want,
well,
there's all sorts of things you don't
want in your garden,
like snakes,
walls don't seem to be much used against
them.
But the idea that paradise is a walled
garden is,
is a,
uh,
an echo back to the chaos order idea,
walls,
culture,
right garden nature.
So the proper human habitat is a
properly tended garden.
Now,
the radical left leaning anti theist
environmentalist's tend to make the case
that the predations of the Western
capitalist system are a consequence of
the injunction that was delivered in
Genesis by God to man to go out and
dominate the earth.
David Suzuki has talked a lot about this
by the way.
They believe that that statement has
given rise to our inappropriate
assumption that we have the right to
exert control over the world and that
that's what's turned us into these
terrible predatory monsters sometimes
described as cancers on the face of the
earth or viruses that have inhabited the
entire ecosystem who are doing nothing
but one wandering everywhere and
wreaking havoc as rapidly as we possibly
can.
Which is another perspective on the
essential element of human kind that I
find absolutely deplorable.
I mean,
if you look at the historical record,
for example,
even casually,
you'll find out that as early as,
as late as the late 18 hundreds,
18,
95,
thereabouts,
Thomas Huxley,
who was Elvis Huxley's grandfather and a
great defender of Darwin,
prepared a report for the British
government on ocean sustainability.
And his conclusion was fish away.
Guys,
man,
there's so many fish out there.
The oceans are so inexhaustible that no
matter how hard humanity tried for,
for any number of years,
the probability that we could do more
than put a dent in what was out there
was zero.
Now Huxley turned out to be wrong.
He didn't realize that our population
was going to spike so dramatically,
partly because we got a little bit rich
and our children's stopped dying at the
rate of like 60 percent before they were
one years old.
And you know,
we actually managed to populate the
earth with a few people,
but it wasn't really until 1960 or so
that we woke up to the fact that there
were so many of us that we actually had
to start paying attention to what we
were doing to the planet.
And that's like what 50 years ago?
Well,
we've just started to develop the
technology,
have the wherewithal to understand that
the whole world might be well considered
a garden,
and we need to live inside the proper
balance between culture and order or
culture and,
and,
and chaos.
Before that,
we were spending all of our time just
trying not to die and usually very
unsuccessfully.
So.
So I don't agree with that
interpretation of the opening section of
Genesis.
I don't believe that it's given human
being is the right to act as super
predators on the planet.
I think that instead the proper
environment for human beings is
presented quite properly as a garden and
that the role of people,
and that's explicitly stated in,
in the second story of Adam and eve,
was to tend the garden.
And that means to make the proper
decisions and to make sure that
everything thrives and flourishes and so
that it's good for the things that are
living there that aren't just people,
but also good for the people too.
So fine.
I think we can.
We could at least note that that's a
slightly different take on the story
than the ultimately cynical
interpretation that's so commonly put
forward today.
Now inside that walled garden is a
couple of trees and Adam and eve and
some animals and all of that,
and unfortunately the tree happens to
have a snake wrapped around it.
Now that's an interesting thing.
We're going to talk about that a lot and
the snake in both of these
representations is no ordinary snake say
it's got a human head and it's got a
human head there too.
So whatever that snake is.
Well,
let forget about looking at this from a
religious perspective,
like if you can just imagine that you're
an anthropologist and you've never seen
this image before.
It's like,
what do you see?
Well,
you see walls and you see something,
a fairly pleasant enclosure,
and then you see a tree and people are
eating from the tree,
but the tree has the snake in it that
has a human head,
and so then you might think,
well,
what's a snake with a human head?
And then you think,
well,
it's half snake and half human.
That's hardly revelatory.
It's just self evidence.
So whatever that snake is isn't just a
snake.
It snake and human or it's,
it's,
it's a snake and partakes in whatever
human beings are.
And that's very important.
So we'll continue.
We'll consider that later.
And you see the same thing here and you
see in this particular version,
there's the head is one also has wings
and so this is a wing snake,
sort of like a dragon.
And so it crawls on the ground like a
reptile and it's got an aerial aspect or
a spiritual aspect.
So here it's a snake,
which is like the lowest form of,
of Reptilian life.
Say something that crawls on the ground.
It's something that's human and
something that's spiritual at the same
time.
And it inhabits the tree,
which look a lot like magic mushrooms by
the way.
And uh,
you can look that up if you want.
That's quite an interesting little
rabbit hole to wander down if you're
curious about it.
Um,
but,
but there's an idea here too,
is that there was something in the
garden at the beginning of time that was
like a snake that was like a person that
was like something that was winged,
something spiritual.
So it's spiritual,
human and Reptilian all at the same
time.
And it's the animating spirit of the
tree.
Okay?
So keep that in mind.
Thus the heavens and the earth were
finished.
This is in relationship to genesis one
and all the host of them.
And on the seventh day,
God ended his work which he had made.
And he rested on the seventh day from
all his work,
which he had made.
And God blessed the seventh day and
sanctified it because that in it,
he had rested from all his work,
which God created the maid.
That's wisdom in that one too.
I think the idea of the sabbath,
you know,
because one of the things I've worked
with a lot of people who were hyper
conscientious and thing about hyper
conscientious people is that they'll
just work till they die and that's
actually not very productive because
then they're dead and they can't work.
And so what you have to do with hyper
conscientious people is you have to say,
well,
I know you'd rather do nothing but work
and maybe you're just as guilty as you
can possibly be when you're not working.
But let's figure out what you're up to
and what you're up to.
In all probability is the attempt to be
productive in the least problematic,
longest sustaining possible manner.
And that might mean you have to take a
rest.
And so one of the things I used to work
with lawyers with people who had risen
to the top of large law firms and they
were hyper productive types and they're
often trying to hit their impossible
quota for yearly hours and,
and burning themselves to a frazzle.
As a consequence.
And one of the things that we used to do
was he couldn't work fewer hours a day
that just didn't work.
But what we did was we'd have them take
more time off,
you know,
like a four day weekend every two months
or something that was plotted out into
the future.
And then we track their billable hours,
which is their degree of productivity.
It would actually increase.
So that was so cool because you could
take hardworking people and you could
say,
look,
you know,
take break.
Why?
Well,
because you'll be more productive if you
take a break.
No,
that couldn't possibly be like,
I should just work flat out all the
time.
It's like,
let's test that out.
You take a break now.
And that it's like,
well,
what happened was their productivity
would increase often by 10 percent.
So there's a,
there's wisdom here too,
which is okay.
And this is alludes to the Adam and Eve
story near the end.
You,
you,
you're self conscious,
you discover the future,
you have to work well.
Then the question is how much should you
work?
And one answer is you better bloody well
work all the time because no matter how
much work you do,
you're not solving your problems.
They're coming along,
man,
and you can stack up all the money you
want,
you can stack up all the wealth you
it is not going to protect you in the
final analysis.
So you better be hitting the ground
running and you better run flat out all
the time.
Or what happens if you do that?
Well then you die.
That's not a good solution.
So maybe you should rest.
And so how does that risk get
instantiated?
Well,
it's not an easy to tell,
but one way to do it,
let's say conceptually is to say,
look,
even God had to rest one day a week.
And so you don't have to be so
presumptuous to assume that if God had
to rest one day a week that maybe you
know,
you are allowed to work nonstop without
a break at all.
You know?
And,
and I think our culture has slipped into
that in quite a dangerous way because
everything is open all the time.
And I mean,
I'm,
I'm find that just as convenient as the
rest of you,
but you know,
it's so strange to talk to modern people
because one of the things they always
tell you,
we say,
well,
how are you and what do they always say?
They don't say good.
They don't say bad.
They say busy.
It's like,
yeah,
well,
okay.
This is where genesis two starts and we
finally got there.
These are the generations of the
heavens,
end of the earth when they were created
in the day that the Lord God made the
Earth and the heavens and every plant of
the field before it was in the earth,
and every herb of the field before it
grew for the Lord.
God had not caused it to rain upon the
earth and there was not a man to till
the ground,
but they're wind type of mist from the
earth and water,
the whole face of the ground.
And the Lord God formed man of the dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life.
And man became a living soul.
Well,
you know,
there's some archaic thinking in there.
The breath is life,
right?
That psyche,
that spirit,
that's inspiration,
that's respiration,
that's all associates.
It's Numa,
pneumatic tire,
it's breath and the reason that people
associated life with breath,
well,
that's not so foolish.
You know,
I mean you're breathing man and
something you do all the time and when
you die you start breathing.
And so the idea that there's something
integral to life about breathing is a
perfectly reasonable supposition.
It actually happens to be very true and
they'll tend to associate the act of
creation with the active first of all,
inspiration and respiration and,
and the breathing of,
of,
of life into something that was inanna.
But is,
is well,
what do you expect for a one sentence
description?
It's not a bad one sentence description,
you know,
so and the Lord God planted a garden
eastward and eaten and eaten means
well-watered place.
And that's particularly relevant I
suppose if you're a desert dweller,
right?
Because the issue there is can you get
enough water to make things grow?
And so the walled garden,
which is paradise,
is also Eden,
which is a well watered place and water
has the element of chaos.
We already saw that in relationship to
genesis one,
where the underlying chaos was often
assimilated symbolically to water.
And so the idea too is that a certain
amount of chaos has to be brought into
the order in order for it to be
fruitful.
And you can see that in the form of of
allowing in the water and out of the
ground made the Lord God to grow every
tree that is pleasant to the sight and
good for food.
The tree of life also in the midst of
the garden and the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil.
So two trees are marked out among the
rest.
One is the tree of life and one is the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
Now you know,
you know when you read something like
that,
if you're thinking about it,
that you're in a metaphorical space.
Now we've got to be careful about
metaphors because you know,
I could say,
and he had that the chaos order idea is
a metaphor,
but then I also said,
well,
wait a second.
It's a metaphor,
but it's also what your brain is adapted
to and so you know,
let's just not be pushing the idea that
it's merely a metaphor to heart and the
same thing is,
is here is happening here.
These are metaphors,
the tree of life and the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil,
but that doesn't exactly mean that
they're mere metaphors because
sometimes,
as I mentioned before and abs,
if you have a set of things and you
abstract out from them a common element,
you can make a strong case that the
common element is more real than the set
of things from which you extracted it.
That's the whole utility.
That abstraction.
Why would you bother with it?
Otherwise,
if you can't take a set of things and
say,
look,
there's something in common across this
set of things that's more important than
the differences between them,
then you wouldn't bother abstracting at
all.
And so the tree of life and the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil are
abstractions.
Now,
one of the questions is,
this is a tough one,
man.
I've been trying.
I tried to figure out for a long time
why have fruit and something you eat
would be associated with the
transformation of psychology because
that's basically what happens in the
Adam and Eve story.
Why would it be something that you eat
now?
Eric Norman,
who was one of young students,
had written a fair bit about this and
God a fairways with it.
And he said,
well,
you know,
we do have noted,
we've noticed forever that the act of
eating,
especially if you're hungry,
especially if you're starving,
produces a rapid spiritual
transformation.
Right?
I mean,
some of you,
this is worth knowing.
You probably have a crabby partner or
child because everyone does.
And one thing you might try is that if
they get erratic during the day and get
all volatile about nothing at all,
it's given them something to eat.
Really.
I'll tell you,
man,
the this solves for.
I do this with my clinical clients all
the time.
It's like they say,
well,
I fly off the handle at the littlest
things.
It's like,
okay,
yeah,
just try this for a week.
When you're crabby and unreasonable,
eat a piece of cheese or eat a peanut
butter sandwich,
eat something that's high protein,
high fat,
and then just wait 10 minutes and see if
you're saying and you'll find out that
you're saying after you eat so often
that you just can't believe how crazy
you are when you're hungry.
Look,
here's.
It's really absolutely bloody
remarkable.
So I'm telling you,
try this.
It'll,
it'll,
it'll.
Especially if you don't eat breakfast,
this will change your life.
And so here,
here's the practical bit of information
for you to,
for all of you,
antisocial types who are going to end up
in prison.
So if you're in prison and you want to
go on parole,
okay,
so you have to go in front of the judge
and tell them why you're not going to do
it again.
So here's the deal.
Here's the deal.
It doesn't really matter what you did
and it doesn't really matter what you
promise.
What matters is whether you see the
judge before lunch or after lunch,
because if you see the judge after
lunch,
the probability that you will get parole
is 60 percent higher.
Yeah,
right.
That is just like so.
Never have an argument with your partner
when you're hungry or when they're
hungry.
Especially if you want something from
them.
It's like,
here's the sandwich.
They'll eat it.
Then there'll be happy.
Then you can manipulate them before,
before that,
man.
No.
So,
you know,
it's not that unreasonable to think that
there's a spirit in food because food
rejuvenates and it just doesn't
rejuvenate you physically.
It rejuvenates you spiritually.
And then of course there's the other
things that we consume that aren't
exactly like food that have a walloping
spiritual impact like alcohol,
let's say,
which is a spirit and is regarded as
[inaudible],
right?
I mean,
it's the god of the vine and the god of
the vine and possesses you in and makes
you act all the fun ways that alcohol
makes you act.
You know,
the fun ways that you regret the next
day.
And uh,
so,
so there's the spiritual element of that
too,
and then,
but there's something even deeper that I
think is so cool that's associated with
food and information because the story
of Adam and Eve represents the fruit as
producing a psychological
transformation.
And so the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil is an abstraction across trees
and it's trying to say here's something
that's common across trees.
It's a fruit that's common across trees.
It's something like that.
And so the fruit across it's common
across trees is something you might call
food.
Fair enough.
That's a.
But here's something that's even more
cool.
The food that's stable across the entire
domain of food isn't food.
It's information,
it's information.
And we use the same bloody circuits in
our brain to forage for information that
squirrels used to forage for food that
animals use to forage for food.
It's the same circuit.
And why is that?
Because we figured out that knowing
where things is,
knowing where the food is more important
than having the food.
And so,
so knowing where the food is,
is a form of mat,
of food information is a form of food
and once you,
well that's why we're information
foragers.
And so once you grasp that and that
ideas is embedded into the story of Adam
and Eve,
so whatever it is that they ingest is a
form of Metta food,
it's,
it's information.
And,
and you know,
we'll trade food for information,
right?
So if you're stuck on the edge of the
highway and you know your,
your hoods up and you're going places,
thing has turned into a pile of junk
that you don't understand and somebody
pulls beside,
pulls up beside you and they're a
mechanic and they point to something to
say,
well,
just put that wire back on there.
You will immediately give them a
sandwich,
right?
Or you offer them something in return.
You know what I mean?
Because they've provided you with
information that has value and it has
value because it actually provides you
with energy because information provides
you with energy.
Because otherwise why would we bother
with it?
And so food provides energy but so does
information.
And so there's the,
there's the idea of food that you
abstract from everything you can eat,
but then there's the idea of what you
could abstract from all sources of food
and the answer to that would be
information and the trees that are being
referred to an Adam and eve are these
method trees.
They're not ordinary trees,
just like paradise is.
No ordinary place,
just like Adam and eve are no ordinary
people and just like the logos that God
is using at the beginning of time is no
ordinary conception and these aren't.
They're not metaphors there more than
metaphors there.
I think of them as hyper realities is
something like that.
Is there more real than what you see
there are more real than the reality
that presents itself to you and lots of
things that are like that,
right?
Numbers are like that.
We wouldn't think or abstract if there
weren't things that were more real than
what we can see.
So what's most real well,
that's partly what we're trying to
figure out and out of the ground made
the Lord God to grow every tree that is
pleasant to this sight.
And good for food,
the tree of life also in the midst of
the garden and the tree of knowledge of
good and evil,
and a river went out of Eden to water
the garden.
And from then,
so it was part of and became into
foreheads.
That's produced a tremendous amount of
speculation.
Now,
you know,
the garden of Eden is also the holy
city.
That's another way of thinking about,
or it's Jerusalem,
right?
Or it's the ideal state,
which could be the ideal city,
or it could be an ideal state of being,
or could be the ideal psyche or it's all
of those things stacked up at the same
time.
Right?
And this is a Mandela,
and this is the Mandela form that
people,
um,
what would you call hypothesized that
constituted the structure of paradise?
He knows it's got this cross form that's
eating itself.
And there's the center eden,
and there's the rivers are rivers,
not snakes.
Those are the rivers that go out of it.
And they're turned into these Mandela
images that are representative of what
you described as the self,
which would be the center element of
being that he associates of conscious
being that he associated with divinity,
I would say,
but also with the idea of the holy city.
And so I'm just showing you that to show
you what were the imagination has taken
ideas of paradise.
So the name of the river is pies and
that is which compensates the whole land
of Avila,
whether is gold and the gold of that
land is good.
There's Bedelia.
I'm in the onyx stone and the name of
the second reverse jihad the same isn't
that compass at the whole land of
Ethiopia.
And the name of the third river is
headache cal or had echo,
I don't know.
That is it.
Which goes towards the east of Assyria.
And the fourth river is the Euphrates.
So there's this strange intermingling
there of geography with mythical
geography.
Right?
Which you see happen fairly frequently
in the books and the Lord God took the
man and put them in the garden of Eden
to dress it and keep it.
Okay.
So that's good,
that's a good command.
That's what you're supposed to do is
take care of the damn thing.
It was a lot of work to make,
right?
Took a whole week,
and the Lord God commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden,
thou mayest freely eat,
but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil,
thou shalt not eat of it for the day
that thou eat thereof,
thou shalt surely die.
While there's this bunch of questions
there that people have been puzzling,
puzzling over for a long time.
Goddy he's a tricky character in the
story of Adam and eve.
It's like,
well,
okay,
if we can't eat the damn thing while why
put it in the garden to begin with,
that would be one question.
And uh,
you made us.
And then you told us not to eat this
knowing perfectly well that the first
thing we were going to do is eat it
because people are of exactly that type,
which is that if you say to them with
their insatiable satiable curiosity,
this is all fine and nice,
but over here is something you should
never look at.
And then you leave the room.
It's like everybody is over there trying
to figure out what the hell that thing
is instantly,
right?
Because we're curious,
curious,
curious creatures.
And so you have to wonder exactly what
God was up to here.
And there's gnostic speculation that the
original God,
this one was not really a very good God.
He was kind of an unconscious evil God
and that he wanted his creation to be
unconscious and so for bade them from
developing consciousness and that it was
a higher God who and maybe in the form
of the serpent who tempted human beings
towards consciousness.
And you know that that idea got scrubbed
out of classic Christianity Pretty
early.
Although there's something that's
interesting about it and there are
remnants of it in different forums that
stayed inside this story.
I'm like the idea that the fall was a
terrible tragedy,
but on the other hand,
it was the precondition for the greatest
event in history,
which was the birth of Christ and the
redemption of mankind.
And so it's complicated.
Let's put it that way.
God only knows what God was up to you,
but uh,
you know,
this is a good example of that
ambivalence.
And to me again,
that it's an indication of the
sophistication of the people who put
these stories together.
I also considered this somewhat
miraculous because,
you know,
if you're just a simple propagandist of
sorts,
you wouldn't leave this sort of
complexity in the text.
You just get rid of that because if
you're a propagandist,
everything is supposed to make sense
along the ideological plane.
Here God is supposed to be good.
It's like,
well,
we better get there to that line because
something's up with it and it isn't
obvious what it is,
but that isn't what people did.
And to me that indicates that that they
were doing two things as they were
trying not to be too careless with the
traditions that they were handed they
they were,
they were touching them at their peril.
They were very careful with them and
also that they were actually trying to
understand what was going on because why
otherwise keep this?
Why not just simplify it or maybe just
attribute this to the devil that would
be easier and having God do it,
but then the Lord God said,
it is not good that man should be alone.
I will make a help meet for him.
None of the ground,
the Lord God formed every beast of the
field and every fall of the air and
brought them unto Adam to see what he
would call them and whatsoever Adam
called every living creature that was
the name thereof.
And Adam gave names to all the cattle in
the fall of the catecholamines.
Animals basically and to the fall of the
error and to every beast of the field.
But for Adam,
there was not found to help meet for
him.
Okay.
Well,
a couple of things.
Their speculations,
number one,
it's like why does God care what Adam
calls the animals and the answer to that
seems to be that it's associated again
with the magic of speech,
right,
so that we know according to the story
that human beings were already made in
the image of God and that God used
language in order to call order from
chaos and that human beings were made in
that image,
and so there's an echo of that here,
even though it's from an independent
tradition and the echo is the thing
isn't quite real until you name it and
that's quite.
And that's,
that's an interesting thing and we don't
exactly know how far that extends.
It's certainly the case that like seem
things often exist in a strange
potential form interconnected forum
where everything's confusing,
like a massive confusion before you put
your finger on it,
name it,
what's going on here?
You name it,
it's like it.
It carves it out from all that
underlying chaos and makes it into a
grippable entity that you can then
contend with.
And you might say,
well,
it was real before you named it.
It's like,
well,
yes,
it was real before you named it the same
way things are there when there's no one
there to perceive them and it isn't
obvious how things are there when you're
not there to perceive the.
I'll tell you something bloody weird
about perception.
You can look this up and John Wheeler,
John,
leaders of physicists,
so here's a really cool thing.
Let's say you go outside at night and
you look up and you see a star and so a
photon from that star enters your eye
and maybe that Fulton has been cruising
along for like $30,
million years.
Do you know that that photon would not
have been emitted from star at that
time?
If you're.
I wasn't there at that time to receive
it.
You think,
well,
how in the hell can that because it
happened 20 million years ago.
It's like,
well,
I don't know how it can be to tell you
the truth,
but I know that John Wheeler has done a
very good job of detailing out why
that's true and necessarily true and so
in wheeler is also the physicist who
developed the notion of it from bit and
he believes that the world is best
construed as the potential of the world
is best construed as a place of
information.
It's something like latent information
and that what consciousness does is
transform the latent interest in
information into something like concrete
reality and he doesn't mean that
metaphorically and one of the cases that
he makes in that regard is this story
that I just told you is that the photon
couldn't have left from where it was
unless it had a place to go.
Now it's.
It's complicated and confusing because
from the perspective of a beam of light
from a full time,
there is no time and there's no distance
from one point to another one.
Of course,
that's completely impossible to
understand too,
but from the perspective of a Photon,
the universe is completely flat,
perpendicular to the direction that the
photon is traveling,
so it's there and here at the same time.
For us it's not,
it's like 20 million years ago,
but for the photon it's all here and
now.
So anyways,
the reason I'm telling you all that is
because the relationship between
consciousness and reality is by no means
straightforward.
It is seriously not straightforward.
And physicists,
physicists debate what the relationship
is between consciousness and reality and
they debate about what the sort of
phenomena that I just described mean,
and I'm not really qualified to enter
into that debate because I'm not a
physicist,
but I do know and I've read a fair bit
of wheeler is about as much of it as I
can understand and I do at least know
that that's what he claimed.
And I also know that that claim is not.
That's a claim that it's taken seriously
among physicists of the caliber of the
physicist who can understand wheeler.
So that's pretty interesting.
So anyways,
there is emphasis again on this
importance of naming in order to make
things real.
You know,
when sometimes people won't name things
just so they don't become real.
So you know if,
if you're,
if you have a relationship,
which undoubtedly you do and it has
problems,
which undoubtedly it does,
you bloody well know that lots of times
there's something under the carpet that
no one wants to name and everybody's
thinking,
well,
as long as we don't name it,
it's not really there.
And in some sense it really isn't there
because you can act as if it's not there
and get away with it at least for short
periods of time.
But as soon as you name that thing,
it's like you give it form and it's
there and no one can ignore it and
that's annoying because then you have to
deal with it or an or or face the
consequences.
But the reason I'm telling you that is
because we have a,
an intuition even that we can have
things not exist by not naming them.
You name it.
And it comes forward with staggering
clarity.
And it's not as if naming it is the only
thing that gives it reality,
but it is something like it sharpens it
and brings it into focus and it gives it
borders and barriers and borders and
boundaries.
And so anyways,
God's interested enough in what Adam has
to say,
that he has a name all the animals and
that sort of makes them into animals.
Now there's more to the linguistic story
than that.
So social psychologists,
Roger Brown was one of them,
studied this really interesting
phenomena which is associated with a
relationship between perception and
action.
You know how a kid will call a
particular animal,
a cat?
Well,
the word cat is very short,
like the word dog.
And it turns out that,
you know,
you could think that we could perceive
cats as multicellular organisms.
Like we could see the self,
we could see the molecules,
we could see the atoms,
we could see where we could see the
ecosystem that the cat is part of,
but we don't.
Or,
or maybe the broader mammalian
classification that it's part of.
We could perceive that as the unit of
perception.
But we don't.
We perceive things at the level of cat
and you can tell the perceptual level
that people naturally perceive that
which doesn't seem to be socio
culturally determined to any great
degree by the way,
because the words are often short and
easily remembered and early learned,
and so there's this level of analysis
out of all the possible levels of
analysis that the world does exist as we
perceive it at a certain level of
analysis and that level of analysis
seems to have something to do with the
world's functional utility.
For us at that level and the perception
at that level and the naming at that
level gives things a reality at that
level.
You know,
because the thing about things is that
they're not easily separable from other
things.
They tangled together and all sorts of
strange ways and yet when we cast our
eye and and,
and use our language to orient ourselves
in the world,
we cut things up into discrete
discriminate objects that we can then
utilize.
And there's something about that that
makes them real in a way that they're
interconnected potential.
The interconnected potential that they
were before that.
That it's not,
it's not real in the same way.
At least I think it's even less real.
I think that's a right way of thinking
about it even though it's not completely
unreal,
but it's an eco.
Adam's a little God at that point,
a little God,
the father and God's already done the
groundwork,
but Adam has to come along and says say,
well,
that's a cat.
It's like poof.
Whatever that is is now a cat and a dog,
and that's a sheep and you know it.
It gives them.
It gives them something like pragmatic
form,
but for Adam,
there was not found a help meet for him
and the Lord God caused a deep sleep to
fall upon Adam and he slept and he and
God took one of his ribs and closed up
the flesh instead thereof,
and the rib which the Lord God had taken
from man made he a woman and brought her
unto the man,
and Adam said,
this is now bone of my bones and flesh
of my flesh.
She shall be called woman because she
was taken out of man.
Therefore shall a man leave his father.
And his mother and shall cleave unto his
wife and they shall be one flesh.
I thought walloping statement to put in
there at the end of those three
sentences mean that therefore it comes
as somewhat of a surprise.
But there's an injunction there.
Well,
it's a good injunction,
man.
I'll tell you,
people who don't,
that they have a hell of a time in their
marriage.
And so this is a good thing to know if
you are married or if you're planning to
get married is like,
you know,
we have very strong orientation towards
our parents and for good reason.
It's like the injunction here is that
secondary,
soon as you're married and,
and failure to do that makes your
marriage collapse and then you deserve
it to collapse too as far as I'm
concerned because it's a reflection of
your pathological immaturity and your
unwillingness to extract yourself from
the grip of parents who are a little bit
too much on the interfering side.
But the injunction,
there's,
there's a deep injunction here.
It's very complicated.
So one of the ideas is that the original
Adam wasn't a man like,
like a separate band.
It was more like a hermaphroditic being
and in that Hymn Afra Didik being there
was a kind of undifferentiated
perfection and then that was split into
male and female and then that part of
the goal of human beings is to reunite
that as the singular unity that
reestablishes the initial perfection and
that's actually the goal of marriage
from a spiritual perspective.
And you could read about that if you
read young because he wrote quite a bit
about that.
So lovely.
It's such a good idea.
So I had these friends that went to
Sweden to get married.
They were more.
They were from northern Alberta,
but his heritage,
they're both.
Their heritage is were Swedish,
Swedish,
and in this ceremony they did this cool
thing as they were being married and
they had to hold a candle up between
them,
right while they were being married.
And you think,
well,
okay,
what's The candle?
That's a source of light,
source of illumination,
right?
Source of enlightenment.
It's the candle that you put on
Christmas trees and in Europe.
So it's the light that emerges in the
darkness and the depth of winter.
It's a symbol of life in,
in,
in darkness.
It's the reemergence of the sun that the
at the darkest,
coldest time of the year,
which is also associated symbolically
with the,
with the birth of Christ,
for all sorts of complicated reasons.
And so the candles,
all that.
And then the next question is why do you
hold it above you?
And the answer is because what's above
you is what?
You're below two.
So it singles to simplify something
transcendent.
And so why do you both hold onto it?
Well,
because you're both supposed to hold
onto the light,
right?
And you're supposed to be subordinate to
the light.
And so you ask,
well,
who's in charge of the marriage?
Well,
the light,
that's the idea.
So you come together as one thing.
You're no longer two things.
It isn't what's good for you and it's
not what's good for your wife.
It's what's good for the marriage.
And the marriage is about the combined
being,
which is the reassembly of the original
Hermes,
Herma,
phronetic,
hermaphroditic being at the beginning of
time.
That's the idea.
And that's all packed into like these
four sentences.
And,
you know,
there's been,
well,
all of these sentences have tremendous
history of interpretation associated
with them,
right?
It's just endless and endless and
endless.
And that's one of the lines.
And so it's also an antidote to the idea
that women taken out of man,
which is obviously the reverse.
The biological process by the way,
makes women in some sense subordinate to
men that is not built into this text.
I don't see that at all,
is built into the text and there's
something else that's associated with it
too.
And there's the idea that,
um,
you know,
in,
in sleeping beauty,
you know,
sleeping beauty goes to sleep.
And the reason she goes to sleep is
because you have to remember what
happens is she has parents who are quite
old and so they're pretty desperate to
have a child,
like so many people are now and they
only have one child like so many people
do now.
And they don't want to think it happened
to this child because like,
hey,
it's a miracle and there's only one of
them.
And so,
and she's the princess.
And so it's like we're not letting
anything around her.
So they have a big christening party,
right.
And the invite everybody,
but they don't invite maleficent and
maleficent is the terrible mother.
She's nature.
She's like the thing that goes bump in
the night.
She's the devil herself,
so to speak.
She's everything that you don't want
your child to encounter.
So the king and queen saying,
well,
we just want to invite her to the
Christening.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
That's an eatable story,
right?
The eatable mother is the mother who
devours her child by refusing,
by overprotecting him or her so that
instead of being strengthened by an
encounter with the terrible world,
they're weakened by too much protection.
And then when they're let out into the
world,
they cannot live.
And that's the story of sleeping beauty.
And that's what the king and Queen do.
And they apologize to the,
to Melissa sent when she first shows up
and say,
well,
you know,
they have a bunch of halfway to the
excuses why they don't invite her.
We forgot.
It's like,
I don't think so.
You know,
you don't forget something like that and
she kind of makes that point.
It's right.
The whole horror of life.
You don't forget about that when you
have a child that's for sure.
You might wish that it would stay at
bay,
but you do not forget about it.
The question is,
do you invite it to the party and the
answer is it bloody well depends how
unconscious you want your child to be
and if you want your child to be
unconscious,
well then you have the added advantage
that maybe they won't leave home and so
you can take advantage of them for the
rest of your sad life instead of going
off to find something to do for yourself
as well.
And then of course you can take revenge
on them if they do have any,
any what would you call impetus towards
courage that you sacrificed yourself 30
years ago and want to stamp out as soon
as you see it developing your child.
That's another thing that would be quite
pleasant,
and so that's what happens in sleeping
beauty.
Yeah.
Well,
none of this is pleasant and nothing
that happens in that story as pleasant,
so sleeping beauty,
she's naive as hell.
They put her out in the forest and have
raised by these three like goody two
shoes,
ferries that are also completely devoid
of any real potency and power,
right?
There's no nothing maleficent about
them.
And then the first idiot prince that
wanders by,
she falls in love with so badly that she
has post traumatic stress disorder
really rides off on his horse,
right?
That's what happens.
And then she,
then she goes into the castle and she's
all freaked out because she met the love
of her life for like five minutes for
God's sake.
And you know,
that's when the spinning wheel,
that's the wheel of fate pops up and she
picks her finger right.
They tried to get rid of all the
spinning wheels.
They tried to get rid of all the wheels
of fate with their pointed end,
but she finds it poked her fingers and
finger falls down unconscious while she
wants to be unconscious and no bloody
wonder.
She was protected her whole life.
She so damn naive that her first love
affair just about kills her.
She wants to go to sleep and never wake
up.
And so that's exactly what happened.
And then she has to wait for the prince
to come and rescue her.
What you think,
how sexist can you get that story?
Well,
seriously,
because that's,
that's the way that that would be red.
And in the modern world it's like she
doesn't need a prince to rescue her.
That's why Disney made frozen that
absolutely appalling piece of rubbish.
So you know,
you can say,
well the princess doesn't need a prince
to rescue her,
but you know,
that's a bone headed way of looking at
the story because the prince isn't just
a man who's coming to rescue the woman
and believe me,
he's got his own problems,
right?
He's got a hold God damn dragon he has
to contend with.
But.
But the prince also represents the
woman's own consciousness.
That consciousness is presented very
frequently in stories as symbolically
masculine as it is with the logo idea.
And the idea is that without,
without that forward going courageous
consciousness,
a woman herself will drift into
unconsciousness and terror and so you
can read it as well.
The woman who's sleeping needs a man to
wake her up and of course just like a
man needs a woman to wake him up.
It's the same damn thing that's the
dragon fight in sleeping beauty.
But it's also the case that if she's
only unconscious,
all she can do is lay there and sleep
the sleep of the naive and damned she
has to wake up,
wake herself up and bring her own
consciousness,
your own masculine consciousness into
the forefront so that she can survive in
the world.
And of course women are trying to do
that like mad.
But that's partly what's represented in
the story like that.
And that's partly what's implicit in
this idea is that unless the woman is
taken out of man,
so to speak,
then she isn't a human being.
She's just a creature.
And that's partly what's embedded in
this story.
So you don't want to read it as a
patriarchal,
don't want to read anything that way.
So really it's really,
it's,
yeah,
I won't,
I won't bother with that,
but really we can do better than that
man.
Therefore shall a man leave his father
and his mother and shall cleave unto his
wife and they shall be one flesh.
It's like,
yeah,
finger.
The other thing about marriage,
this is really worth knowing too,
is that I learned this in part from
reading youngest,
like what do you do when you get
married?
That's easy.
You take someone who's just as useless
and horrible as you are,
and then you shackle yourself to them
and then you say,
we're not running away no matter what
happens.
Yeah.
Well that's perfect because then you
don't get to run away.
And the thing is,
is like if you can run away,
you can't tell each other the truth
because if you tell someone the truth
about you,
they don't run away.
They weren't listening.
And so if you don't have someone around,
they can't run away,
then you can't tell them the truth.
And so that's part of the purpose of the
marriage.
It's like,
okay,
I'll bet on you.
You bet on me.
It's a losing battle.
We both know that,
but given our current circumstances were
unlikely to find anyone better,
that's for sure.
No
two things that come off of that.
One is,
you know,
people are waiting around to find Mr and
Mrs.
Right?
It's like,
here's something to think about,
man,
to put yourself on your feet.
Right?
If you went to a party and you found Mr
Wright and he looked at you and didn't
run away screaming,
that would indicate that he wasn't Mr
Wright at all.
Right?
It's like the old Nietzschean joke.
If someone loves you,
that should immediately disenchant you
with them.
Right?
Right.
Or it's the woody Allen joke.
I never belonged to a club that would
take me as a member.
So.
So that's,
that's an interesting.
That's a very interesting thing to think
about and so you're going to shackle
yourself to someone who's just as far as
imperfect as you are.
And then the issue is you,
you,
you might be in a situation where you
can actually negotiate because you might
think,
well,
there's some things about you that
aren't going so.
Right.
And there's some things about me that
aren't going so right and we're bloody
well stuck with the consequences for the
next 50 years.
So we can.
We can either straighten this out or we
can suffer through it for the next five
decades and you know people are of the
sort that without that degree of
seriousness,
those problems will not be solved.
You'll leave things unnamed because
there's always an out and this the same
thing when you're living together with
someone.
You know that people who live together
before they're married are more likely
to get divorced,
not less likely.
And the reason for that is,
what exactly are you saying to one
another when you live with each other?
Just think about it.
Well,
for now you're better than anything
else.
I can trick,
but I'd love to reserve the right to
trade you in conveniently.
If someone beat her,
happens to stumble into me,
well,
how can.
How could someone not be insulted to
their core by an offer like that?
Now they're willing to play along with
it because they're going to do the same
thing with you that.
Well,
that's exactly it.
It's like,
yeah,
I know you're not going to commit to me,
so that means you don't value me or our
relationship above everything else,
but as long as I get to escape,
if I need to,
then I'm willing to put up with that.
It's like,
that's a hell of a thing.
I mean,
you might think,
how stupid is it to shackle yourself to
someone?
It's like,
it's stupid,
man.
There's no doubt about that.
But compared to the alternatives,
it's pretty damn good because without
that shackling,
there are things you will never ever
learned because you'll avoid them.
You can always leave and if you can
leave then you don't have to tell each
other the truth.
It's as simple as that because you can
just leave and then you don't have
anyone.
You can tell the truth too.
So there's some representations of the
idea of the original.
It's not.
This isn't all Adam,
this is,
this is an old Chinese symbol.
I think it's fuck and new.
Uh,
I think I have the pronunciation wrong,
but it's really cool.
See,
it's.
See the snakes down here.
They're kind of like a DNA symbol,
which I find very interesting,
and so that's the original cosmic
serpent that's sort of the potential out
of which that emerges and then that's
the differentiation of that into male
and female and so that's like the
predatory unknown.
That's one way of thinking about it.
That's the most fundamental conception
of mankind is something like that is the
predatory unknown and then the
bifurcation of that into the two
fundamental cognitive elements of human
perception,
masculine and female,
and you see the same thing here.
This is Chinese.
This is Egypt,
also extraordinarily old.
It's the.
It's the great serpent that underlies
everything.
Ma indicating itself into Isis,
queen of the underworld,
and Cyrus King of the King of King of
King Pharaoh,
King of order.
You see the same thing in the middle of
Dow chemical symbol.
I love this one.
Does it looks quite a lot like the
little thing that Harry Potter chases
around A.
Yeah,
and that's not accidental by the way,
because the seeker is the same.
The thing that chases this and the
seeker that chases this and catches that
wind and that's a really old idea and
how the Hell j Dot k rowling knew that I
cannot figure out because that is a
very,
very archaic symbol,
arcane symbol on Google.
It's called the round chaos and the only
reference to the round chaos that I can
find on Google is on my webpage and so I
have no idea how Rollin came up with
that.
I mean,
I know she looked at a lot of old texts,
but the idea that if you play the
metagame and you catch this,
you win all the Games is exactly right
in that.
And that's the for.
What's the name of that quidditch?
Yeah,
so there's the potential that's like the
potential out of which God made the
world at the beginning of time and what
emerges out of that is some kind of.
That's a dragon.
The dragon fight.
That's partly the serpent that's in the
garden of Eden and then that's the
manifestation of masculine and feminine.
Out of that potential predatory,
unknown,
masculine and feminine.
It's like a single.
It's like a single representation of the
evolutionary history of human cognitive
consciousness,
so cool,
and then it's also an image of the
ideal.
It's the Union of sun and moon and it's
this hyper creature hermaphroditic
that's also the Adam and eve that
existed at the beginning of time before
the fall,
and it's the purpose of marriage.
All of that as a sacrament.
All of that in these images.
It's just absolutely unbelievable what
images can pack into them and there's
some more classical representations of
eve being extracted from Adam
and this is a cool line and they were
both naked.
The man and his wife and were not
ashamed.
Well that.
See someone who wrote that would only
write that like that if they were
surprised that they weren't ashamed
because why would you point it out
otherwise?
And so there's this intimation that have
two things.
Number one is there was a point at time
in time when human beings were naked and
they weren't ashamed of it,
and there is a point of time which is
now where they're naked and they are
ashamed of it.
And then the question is,
well,
what's the association with nakedness
and shame?
And that's often given a sexual
connotation in,
in classic interpretations of the Adam
and Eve story because of its association
with nudity,
I presume.
But I think it's a lot more complicated
than that.
So I think,
I know I noticed my daughter,
she probably won't be very happy that
I'm revealing this in this lecture,
but my daughter was never really
concerned about nudity when she was a
little kid and it was all the same to
her one way or another.
But my son by the time he was three man,
that kid was private.
He,
his,
his bedroom door was shut,
the bathroom door was shut.
It was like get the hell out of here.
And that seemed to just happen of its
own accord.
And you know,
we had two children and one was like
that and the other one wasn't.
I didn't think we had much to do with it
at all.
But it was really fascinating to watch
that emerge in him.
And you know that that sense of,
of self consciousness does seem to
emerge in children somewhere around the
age of three.
And you know,
that's generally also when we start
thinking that maybe having your baby
wander around naked on a beach isn't
exactly the best idea.
There's,
there's,
there's something like that.
It's the nudity in children is generally
okay under some circumstances in public
display.
We seem to think of that as merely I
succeptible why might,
I dunno why it stops being acceptable.
Well that has something to do with
sexuality obviously,
but it's a very complicated phenomena.
But you know,
that whole nudity thing is the,
is a very complicated thing.
I mean,
first of all,
people are kind of strange because we're
hairless roughly,
you know,
compared to most animals.
And we don't know why that is.
Some people think it's because we lost
our hair when we were wandering around
in the desert,
in the desert running around in Africa
because we're really,
really good runners.
We can run down animals,
say like a human being in good shape can
run a horse to death in a week.
We can really run man and had a lot of
our ancestors,
the Kalahari Bushman still do this.
They just run an animal for it till it
dies and that Bushman doesn't die.
I mean they also sometimes shoot them
with poison arrows but they can just run
them until they die.
So we have tremendous endurance and you
and you have to be able to get rid of a
lot of heat if you're going to run
around in the desert.
So we don't have much hair.
That's one explanation.
And Buckminster Fuller had an
interesting explanation which was he
thinks that at some point during our
evolution we spend a lot of time near
the water and so we're like fish apes,
something like that.
Well,
you know,
we like to be on the beach and there's
lots of food there and we like to swim
and we're really good at swimming for
terrestrial creatures and we,
we cry salt.
Here's like some seagoing creatures too.
And women have a layer of subcutaneous
fat,
like some going creature stew and we
have kind of our feet are,
which are very odd.
Things are kind of good for flapping in
the water,
although we can also walk with them.
And so he thought that maybe that
adaptation was to,
to,
uh,
a water existence like seals and so
forth,
like we kind of went back to the ocean
but not quite and so,
but anyways,
the evolution of that hairlessness is an
interesting thing,
but it certainly does make us exposed to
the world in a way that animals that
have a covering a for art and then we're
upright,
which is very strange because most
animals aren't there on all fours.
And so they're very vulnerable.
Parts are protected and not exposed to
view.
And then of course,
when you're standing up nude,
your,
your fears,
let's call it your psychophysiological
quality is on painful display,
right?
And people complain about that all the
time.
You know,
if you look at the feminist tack for
example,
on,
but the idea that women have eating
disorders is,
is directly attributed to the presence
of too many beautiful women on the cover
of magazines.
Something like that.
Even though women by those magazines and
they're attracted to the band,
their mood goes up when they purchase
them and the if the,
if the stimulus was a negative,
that women would avoid the magazines and
not by them.
So as a theory it's a very,
very bad one,
but it's still the case that,
you know,
it's still the case,
that standards of beauty,
shame people and that's for sure and
everyone,
because if you're not ugly now,
man,
you're going to be at some point in your
life.
So that's kind of a rough thing to
contend with.
Right?
It's,
it's a rough thing to,
to know that,
that there's an ideal that you could be
and maybe even once we're,
that you're not going to be for long or,
or,
or never were.
And it's really an appalling issue
because I think it's harder on women
because women are judged by men more for
their,
for their youth and fertility.
That's how it turns out from an
evolutionary point of view.
Men are judged more on their
socioeconomic status by women.
It's harsh both ways,
but so anyways,
it's,
you know,
it's a terrible thing to,
to carry the knowledge with you that
you're exposed to the most serious
possible evaluation of the quality of
your being that you can possibly be
exposed to all the time and that that's
further amplified if you're without
clothing.
And so part of clothing is protection,
but a tremendous amount of it is merely
stopping other people from evaluating
you too harshly all the time.
It just gets in the way.
So anyways,
this store,
this,
this story makes the case that at some
point we weren't like that.
Well,
animals aren't like that.
So it seems perfectly plausible in at
some point we weren't like that,
but at some point that changed.
And,
and they were both naked,
the man and his wife and were not
ashamed.
Now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field,
which the Lord God had made.
And he said unto the woman,
yea,
have God said you shall not eat of every
tree of the garden.
I like this.
This is,
um.
Oh,
I can't remember who did the etching.
Now,
who is it?
Dra.
Yeah,
Delray.
Exactly.
Hee.
He duray did etchings for paradise lost
that are absolutely remarkable and this
is Satan and this is the snake here.
And of course in the genesis story,
Satan is weirdly associated with the
snake.
And I'll tell you that's a.
that's a,
that's a tough one to sort out because
in the story of Adam and eve,
there no indication whatsoever that the
serpent who cam see there's also Satan,
the author of all evil and how in the
world those two stories got tangled
together.
Well,
I think I figured that out and I'm going
to tell you that tonight,
but it took a very long time to figure
it out.
And it's absolutely.
It's so bloody brilliant.
I just can't believe that people figured
it out.
It's so.
It's so unbelievably spectacularly
brilliant.
And that's a,
that's a,
an intimation of that idea,
right?
That there's a kinship between these two
things.
So anyways,
the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field.
Subtle.
It's an interesting word.
This is from the Oxford English
dictionary.
So [inaudible] will amplify the word
about this is what you do in union dream
interpretation,
for example,
is to kind of look at the connotations
of the concepts that are associated with
the dream subtle of a person or animal
and action behavior.
Crafty,
cunning,
sly,
treacherous.
So it's something that's sort of sneaks
along,
right?
It,
it's not something that you really pick
up on that easily have a look or glance.
Sly Furtive,
surreptitious of a person,
skillful expert,
clever of a work of art,
mechanical device cleverly made or
designed ingenious well that that's.
I think that's all fairly.
All those terms so far,
fairly well attributed to snakes.
I mean they are very cool things and and
they are very well designed and they're
quite remarkable and they're also very
subtle on the nature of or involving
careful discrimination of fine points or
five points.
Difficult to understand and abstruse of
a person,
the mind or intellectual activity,
intellectual activity characterized by
wisdom or perceptiveness.
Discriminating,
discerning and true.
That's interesting because Milton,
Satan is also the intellect and you
know,
you see that very often.
You know,
it's so often the bad guys,
an evil scientist,
right,
and there's something about it.
You see the same thing in the lion king
with scar,
I mean scars and intellect and arrogant,
deceitful intellect piece.
There's nothing stupid about scar.
He's not wise,
but he's the.
He's the evil voice that's always
whispering in the king's ear and that's
associated with the pride of the
intellect and the Catholics had warned,
warned humanity about the pride of the
intellect for centuries.
Now,
it's partly what produced somewhat of
the schism between Catholicism and
science,
although that's much overstated.
If you look at the historical record,
the idea was that the intellect has its
own particular.
It's a remarkable faculty.
Let's say it's the highest angel in
God's heavenly kingdom.
That's the way that Milton portrayed it,
but it's also the thing that can go most
terribly wrong because intellect,
the intellect can become arrogant about
its own existence and accomplishments
and it can fall in love with its own
products and that's what happens when
you're ideologically possessed because
you end up with a dogma like say a human
constructed dog,
Mine Solzhenitsyn's words that possesses
you completely have which you believe is
100 percent right.
Right?
So it eradicates the necessity for
anything transcendent and so that's the
element of the intellect that's
associated symbolically with the snake
in the garden of paradise,
of a feeling sense,
sensation,
acute and keen involving distinctions
that are find her delicate especially to
such an extent as to be difficult to
discern or analyze.
Also almost imperceptible and elusive.
Having little thickness or breadth,
thin fine sub teal matter.
Now,
historical rarefied matter,
barely there at all,
and the woman said unto the serpent,
we may eat of the fruit,
of the trees,
of the garden,
but of the fruit of the tree which is in
the midst of the garden,
Goth is God,
has said,
you shall not eat of it.
Neither shall you touch it,
lest you die.
The serpent said to the woman,
Ye shall not surely die.
For God doth know in the day that you
eat thereof.
Then your eyes shall be opened and you
shall be as gods knowing good and evil.
Sneaky,
subtle.
It's a nice story.
The first thing is the for instance.
The instant implication is,
well,
you can't trust God,
so that's pretty sneaky.
In the next is what he's trying to.
He's trying to pull a fast one on you
and the next one is what?
He's trying to do that because he's
jealous and he doesn't want you to know
things that he knows because that
wouldn't be so good and he's lying to
you anyways because you're not going to
die,
and if you eat it contrary to what
you've been informed,
then all that's going to happen is your
eyes will be open and you'll be like
gods knowing good and evil.
That sounds pretty damn good.
So you know a night,
I mean eve,
but does she know?
You know?
It's no wonder she's susceptible to such
blandishments and it's quite interesting
too because Adam and Eve,
God tells Adam and eve not eat the damn
fruit,
but they never promise not to write,
so they haven't promised.
They've just been told to and well,
we should.
They be obedient.
Well,
how obedient do you want your children
to be?
You want them to be obedient enough so
they don't get hurt,
but disobedient enough so that they go
out in the world and do something
courageous and they break some rules
that they learned some things and so you
know it's,
it's,
it's a very paradoxical story.
Anyways,
the serpent,
when wins this round man,
and so eve pays attention to the snake.
So again,
we have the same set of images,
right?
We have an adamant,
we have eve,
we have this tree,
and we have this strange serpent that's
a dragon like form there,
a sphinx like form that's associated
with the tree snakes eternally
associated with a tree.
Well,
the snake was eternally associated with
the tree.
We spent,
God only knows how many tens of millions
of years as tree dwelling primates and
the primary or one of our primary
predators.
We had three primary predators,
snakes,
birds,
cats,
and so the snake has been associated
with the tree for a very,
very long time.
And the lesson,
the snake tells people you bloody well
better wake up or something you don't
like,
we'll get you and who's going to be more
susceptible,
susceptible to paying attention to the
snake,
and that's going to be eve.
And the reason for that is eve has
offspring and there's nothing tastier to
a snake than a child.
And so eve had every reason to be self
conscious and neurotic and women are
more self conscious and neurotic than
men by quite a substantial amount.
And that's true cross culturally and in
emerges out of puberty.
And part of the reason is,
as far as we can tell,
is that women are more sexually
vulnerable.
There are also smaller.
So that's a problem if you're engaged in
any physical alteration.
But most importantly,
I think is that why would you ever
assume that a human females nervous
system is adapted to her or her
wellbeing?
Why wouldn't you assume a stead that her
nervous system is adapted to the female
infant dyad?
Because if it isn't,
then the infants die.
And so you might take,
while women are way more susceptible to
depression and anxiety than men are.
And that's a hell of a burden to bear.
And that's also true cross-culturally,
by the way.
And it also kicks into puberty and the
biggest differences are in Scandinavia
for those of you who think it's
socio-cultural,
which it isn't.
So,
but there's reasons for it.
You know,
I didn't also at puberty when men,
men and women start to become sexually
dimorphic in terms of size and men are
way more powerful in their upper bodies.
It's in comparatively more powerful and
so that makes them a lot more dangerous
and human.
The human primary human defense
mechanism is punching like with
Kangaroos for because there's some other
animals that punch chimps can punch too,
but human beings,
it's a punch and most of the forest and
that his upper body and shoulder and so
a woman's no match for a man in a fight,
so she has every reason to be nervous,
especially when you add that to that her
additional sexual vulnerability and the
fact that she has to take care of
extraordinarily dependent.
Infants were extremely fragile for a
very long period of time and so she had
every and women are more self conscious
than man.
The empirical literature on that is
clear.
It's associated with trait neuroticism
because self consciousness is actually
an unpleasant emotion.
Who wants to be self conscious?
If I'm self conscious on the stage
talking to you,
then all of a sudden I can't even talk
to you.
All I'm doing is thinking about me in
all the things that are wrong with me
and I fall inside myself.
It's like selfconsciousness,
although it's a great gift,
let's say is nothing pleasant.
It's associated primarily with anxiety.
So we've had every reason to pay
attention to the snake,
that's for sure.
I think I read this week that among,
I can't remember which tribesmen at
where it was,
unfortunately,
although I did put a footnote in my new
book about this,
um,
these,
these were jungle dwelling tribal
people.
Five percent of the adults had been
attacked by a python and a substantial
number of children had been killed by
them.
So snake predation was no joke.
It's shaped our evolutionary past and
still is no joke in many places.
And so we're attuned to snakes.
And the thing is,
as Lynn has bell pointed out now,
anthropologists,
we got really good at detecting the
camouflage patterns of snakes,
especially in the lower half of our
visual field.
And there's evidence that part of the
reason that human beings have such acute
vision,
which means that our eyes opened,
let's say,
is because we were,
we call evolved with snakes and we
learned how to see them and then the
price we paid for seeing was that our
brain grew because you need a lot of
brain to be able to see.
And the consequence of our brain growing
is one day we woke up and discovered the
future and the future is where all the
snakes might live instead of where they
live right now.
So there's that same thing in the same.
So interesting.
Again,
these images you see in this one,
you have the specter of death in the
tree with the snake and the fruit and
fruit is interesting to already make the
case that there's a tight linkage
between what you eat and information,
right?
A conceptual link as well as the
practical link.
But it's also the case that we can see
colors.
And the question is why?
And the answer is because we evolved to
see ripe fruit.
So in the story of Adam and Eve,
human beings are given vision by the
snake and the fruit and that turns out
to be correct.
So isn't that something?
And then you think,
what role do women play in relationship
to men?
Well,
first they make themselves conscious.
Let's not ever forget about that because
the.
I would say the primary role that women
have in relationship to men is to make
them self conscious.
And men don't precisely like that.
There's nothing that will make a man
more self conscious than being rejected.
And why?
Because why is he rejected?
Well,
obviously mother nature in the guise of
that particular woman has said,
you're not so bad for a friend,
but there's no reason that your genetic
material should propagate itself into
the future.
Right?
Well,
and it's not like men are exactly happy
about being made,
made self conscious by women,
right?
It's a major source of continual tension
between men and women and it's no
wonder,
but it's also the case and this is
something really cool and interesting to
know.
You know,
you do,
you've divulged dive,
divulged,
die,
whatever.
That's it diverged.
We diverged from the common ancestor
between us and chimpanzees about 6
million years ago.
Here's why,
at least in part,
chimpanzee females are non discriminant
maters.
They'll mate with any mail when they go
into heat,
which human females don't when they go
into heat than any male is allowed
access.
Now the dominant males chased the
subordinate males away and so the
dominant males are more likely to leave
offspring,
but it's not because of the female
choice.
It's not the case with human beings.
Human females engage in hyper and
hypoglycemia is the,
and this is also true cross culturally
and it's also quite as extensive in
Scandinavia,
not quite.
There's a bit of attenuation,
but not much.
Women mate across and up.
Dominance hierarchies,
manmade across and down.
Okay,
well,
and that has to be the case because it
obviously has to work that way.
If one goes up,
the has to go down.
The socioeconomic status of a woman is
almost determined almost zero of her
attractiveness towards a man.
Whereas the socioeconomic status of a
man is a major determinant of his
attractiveness towards a woman and it
isn't as well either because that's been
tested.
It's his capacity to generate and be
productive and to share because that
beats the hell out of wealth.
Wealth can disappeared,
right,
but the capacity to be productive and
share,
that's,
that's a much more important element and
why not be chosen on the basis of that,
especially because women have to have
infants and infants make the women
dependent and the woman is just looking
logically,
rationally and from an evolutionary
perspective for someone who is useful
enough to give a hint to lend a hand.
So women make intense demands on men and
it's no wonder,
but the thing is is that because women
engaged in hyperglycemia,
at least in part,
we diverge quite rapidly from
chimpanzees because the selection
pressure that women placed on men
develop the entire species.
Now there's two things that happened as
far as I could tell.
The men competed for competence,
let's say.
So the male hierarchy is a mechanism
that pushes the best man to the top
virtually by definition,
and then that's,
that's the effect of that is multiplied
by the fact that women who are Pergamon
as peel from the top and so that the
males who are the most competent are
much more likely to leave offspring and
that seemed to be what drove our
cortical expansion,
for example,
which happened very,
very rapidly over the course of
evolutionary time.
So,
and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and that it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her.
And he did eat.
Oh yes.
And women share food.
That's a very strange thing because most
creatures don't do that,
right?
Most animals don't share food.
Like if you,
if you're a wolf and you bring down
something in a hunt,
you eat your fill.
The dominant creatures eat their fill.
And then if there's some leftover,
this subordinate t too,
but that isn't how human beings work.
We share food.
Now you can imagine how that evolved
because lots of female creature share
food with their offspring.
Okay?
You don't need much of a twist in that
from an evolutionary perspective until
you start to share food,
not only with your offspring say,
but with your mate,
and that's another way that you entice a
mate.
It's like we're going to be better
together than alone.
Well,
that's the offering of the fruit.
what's the self conscious part?
Well,
here's part of the bargain.
You know I'm going to wake you up and
partly I'm going to wake you up because
you need to be woken up because I have
this infant that needs some damn care
and so you bloody well better be awake
and part of the bargain is all offer you
something.
I'll offer you some food and in response
we're going to make a team and that's
the deal.
Well,
that's the human deal and that's why
we're more or less monogamous by why we
more or less pair of bond and why
something approximating marriage is a
human universal.
It's cross cultural.
Now you can find exceptions,
but who the hell cares?
The vast,
really man,
who cares?
If you look at the vast pattern,
the vast pattern,
while in the price we pay for having
large brains is that we are very
dependent and it takes a long time for
us to get programmed and because of that
we need relatively stable family bonding
and that's basically what we've evolved
and you know,
you don't get that without making men
self conscious because male creatures,
why not impregnate and run?
I mean why the hell not?
And that's something to really,
no kidding,
like that's the thing to think about.
It is not why men abandoned their
children.
That's the mystery.
It's why any men ever stick with them.
That's the mystery because you just have
to look at the animal kingdom and the
like.
The simplest and easiest thing is always
the most likely thing to occur.
So it's the exception.
That longterm commitment that needs
explanation.
She took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her and he did eat the eyes of both of
them were opened.
Implying that before that they were
closed and they knew they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons.
So that's so interesting.
So their eyes are open,
which indicates that they weren't to
begin with.
So whatever God created to begin with
was kind of blind in but not blind in
some strange way because they weren't
obviously wanting to run into garden,
bumping into trees.
It was some sort of metaphysical
blindness that's been removed by
whatever has just happened and
whatever's just happened.
Also made them realize that they were
naked.
Okay.
So what sort of eye opening is that?
What does it mean to realize that you're
naked means to realize that you're
vulnerable.
That's what people discovered.
It's like,
oh,
we can be hurt.
So you're a zebra in a herd of zebras
and there's a bunch of lions around.
They're laying on the grass.
You don't care.
Those are laying down lions,
laying down lines or no problem.
It standing up hunting lions that are
the problem.
You're not smart enough to figure out
that laying down lines turn into
standing up hunting lions,
so you're not building a fort to keep
the lions out.
You're just mindlessly eating grass.
You're not very awake,
but that's not what happens to human
beings is they wake up and they think
we're vulnerable permanently.
It's never going away.
Right?
It's the.
It's the recognition of that internal
vulnerability.
What happens?
The first thing they do is clothe
themselves.
Well,
what happens when you're naked?
When you need protection from the world
will obviously.
Look,
you're all wearing clothes.
You know why?
Well,
we've been doing that for a very,
very long period of time.
It's tens of thousands of years at
minimum.
In fact,
you can track more or less when clothing
developed because you can do DNA testing
of the kind of life that cleaned clothes
rather than heroin.
So we have a pretty good idea of when
clothing emerged and have different
types as well,
so that's quite cool.
But the point is they're naked and they
think that's not so good.
We're vulnerable so their eyes were open
enough so they become self conscious and
they recognize their own vulnerability
and the first thing they do is the first
step of culture is to protect themselves
with something from the world and you
protect yourself from the world and from
the prying eyes of other people.
This is the book by Lynn Bell,
why we see so well from the temptation
of eve to the venomous murder of the
mighty thor.
The serpent appears throughout time and
culture as a figure of mischief and
mystery misery.
The worldwide prominence of snakes in
religion,
myth and foreclosure underscores our
deep connection to the serpent,
but why?
When so few of us have firsthand
experience.
The surprising answer,
this book suggests lies in the singular
effect of snakes on primate evolution.
Predation pressure from snakes,
Lynn is tells us,
is ultimately responsible for this
superior vision and large brain of
primates and for a critical aspect of
human evolution that was tested
recently.
Psychologists have known for a long time
that people are can learn fear to
snakes,
but they discovered in primates recently
a set of neurons,
Paul Dinner,
neural neurons which are specialized,
that's an old,
old perceptual systems revealed
neurobiological evidence of past
selection for rapid detection of snakes,
so that's from 2013,
so the snake definitely woke us up.
Color Vision as an adaptation to fruit
eating in primates.
It's not by accident that women make
themselves look like ripe fruit in order
to be attractive to men.
Right?
And that's also not socio-cultural in
origin.
So,
and they heard the voice of the Lord God
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day,
and Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God
amongst the trees of the garden.
That's interesting.
So what's the implication prior to being
woken up prior to recognizing nakedness
and vulnerability,
there was no reason for God,
for man and woman to hide from God.
Now where they're hiding from God while
they're naked,
they're vulnerable.
Okay,
so think about this.
Think about this.
It's like imagine that you have the
capacity to live truthfully and
courageously and forthrightly.
Just imagine that and then imagine why
you might not do that and then imagined,
well,
how about fear and shame?
How?
How would that work?
Well,
let's say that the idea of living
forthright,
Lee and truthfully and courageously is
analogous,
given what we already know about these
stories,
to walking with God in the garden.
Well,
what stops people from doing that?
What stops people from hiding?
Well,
it's their own rates or recognition of
their own inadequacy.
They look at themselves and they think,
how in the world is a creature cinches I
supposed to live properly in this world
with everything that's wrong with me,
and so what do you hide from?
Well,
you go home,
you sit on your bed for five minutes and
ask yourself,
what have you hidden from in your life?
Man,
you'll have books of knowledge reveal
themselves to you and your imagination,
right?
Say,
well,
why are you hiding?
Well,
it's no wonder you're hiding.
It's no wonder that people hide.
That's the thing that's so terrifying
about this story.
We woke up and we thought,
oh my God,
look at this place like this is
seriously.
There's some serious trouble here and
we're in some serious trouble and we're
not what we could be,
and so we hide and that's what the story
says.
People woke up,
they became self conscious.
They recognized their own vulnerability
and that made the.
Made them hide from manifesting their
divine destiny.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly right,
and the Lord God there,
I love this part of the story and it's
so funny and the Lord God called and we
could use a little humor at this point,
and the Lord God called Unto Adam and
said unto him where Art Thou?
And Adam said,
I heard that voice in the garden and I
have.
I was afraid because I was naked.
So in case there was any doubt about
that.
That's why.
And I hid myself and God said,
who told you that you were naked?
Did you eat of the tree whereof I
commanded you that you should not eat.
And this is where Adam shows himself in
all his post fall,
heroic glory.
And the man said,
the woman
whom now gave us to be with me,
she gave me of the tree and I did eat.
So that set,
that set that it's so,
you know,
again,
there's a modern feminist interpretation
of the story of Adam and eve that makes
the claim that eve was portrayed as the
universal bad guy of humanity for
disobeying God and eating the Apple.
It's like,
fair enough.
You know,
it looks like she slipped up.
Then she tempted her husband and you
know,
that makes her even worse.
Although he's was foolish enough to
immediately eat.
So it just means she was a little more
courageous than him then got there
first.
But it's Adam who comes across as really
one sad creature in this story as far as
I'm concerned about.
He manages in one sentence.
It's like,
first of all,
it wasn't him.
It was the woman and said,
can even blames God.
It wasn't just the woman who was,
it was that woman and you gave her to
me.
Then she gave me of the tree and I did
eat.
It's like,
so hay Adams,
all innocent.
Except now he's not only is he naked and
disobedient and cowardly and ashamed,
he's also sniffily backbiting.
Think he writes her out like the second
he gets the opportunity and then he
blames God.
It's like,
and that's exactly right.
That's exactly right,
man.
You go online and you read,
you read the commentary that men write
about women when they're resentful and
bitter about women.
You read it.
It's so interesting.
It's like,
it's not me.
It's those bitches.
Okay,
that's right.
It's not me.
It's them.
And not only that,
what are bloody world,
this is in which they exist.
It's exactly the same thing.
It's exactly the same thing and it is
absolutely pathetic.
All right,
and the Lord God said unto the woman,
what is this that thou has done?
And the woman said,
the serpent beguiled me and I did eat
while he.
She has a bloody excuse.
First of all,
it's a snake.
I mean,
those things aren't.
We already found out there is subtle and
second it turns out that the damn snake
is Satan himself.
You know,
when he's rather treacherous.
So the fact that she got tangled up in
his mess,
let's say,
is well problematic,
but it's a lot better excuse that Adam
has and the Lord God says unto the
serpent,
because thou has done done this,
cursed above all cattle and above every
beast of the field upon thy belly shalt
they'll go and dust shalt thou eat all
the days of their life.
And snakes by the way,
are lizards that lost their legs,
just so you know.
And I will put enmity between the and
the woman and between thy seed and her
seed,
it shall bruise thy head and thou shalt
bruise his heel.
I love these pictures.
They're so smart.
And again,
strip the religious context from them
and just look at them for a second.
What do you see?
You see the eternal mother holding her
infant away from the snake.
See it down there,
right?
Crocodile snake.
Everything predatory.
That's been after us for like 60 million
years.
The reason we're here is because of
that.
That's why it's a sacred image.
Now this one I like even better.
See down there,
there's something like the moon and then
there's this a reptile down there that
even standing on,
this is really old.
I showed you this before,
but I think it's so cool.
She's coming out of this thing that's
like a hole in the sky,
you know,
because it it.
It indicates the eternal presence of
this figure.
It's something like that.
The eternal recurrence of this figure.
It's an archetype,
but then the the,
the potential out of which she is
emerging.
These are all musical instruments back
here and so what the artist is
representing is the great pattern
complexity of being and the emergence of
of the protective mother.
From that background,
protecting the infant eternally against
predation.
It's like,
how can that not be a holy image if it
isn't the holy image?
If you don't think it's a holy image,
then there isn't something wrong with
the image.
There's something wrong with the
perceiver unto the woman.
He said,
well,
God's just outlining the consequences of
this right now.
It's like,
okay,
well now you've gone and done it.
You've woken up.
This is what's going to happen.
I will greatly multiply that Isaura.
When I conception in sorrow,
thou shalt bring forth children and they
desire shall be to that husband and he
shall rule over thee.
Say he should says he will,
and why
in sorrow shall they'll bring forth
children.
Well,
when you develop a brain that big so
that you can see it's not that easy to
give birth anymore and then you produce
something that's dependent beyond belief
and that's one of the things that you
would say dooms you to precisely this,
so that's eaves punishment for waking up
and Adam because thou has hearkened unto
the voice of thy wife and has eaten of
the tree,
of which I commanded thee,
saying,
thou shalt not eat it.
Cursed is the ground for thy Sake,
in sorrow shall thou eat of it in all
the days of their life.
What's that?
The invention of work.
Thorns and thistles shall it bring forth
to thee and now shall eat the herb of
the field.
It's the invention of work.
What do people do that animals don't
work?
What does work mean?
It means you sacrifice the present for
the future and why do you do that?
Because you know you're vulnerable and
because you're awake and so from here on
end and from this point there's no
return to unconscious paradise.
I don't care how many problems you've
solved so that today's okay.
You've got a lot of problems coming up
and no bloody matter how much you work.
You never going to work enough to solve
them and so all you're going to do from
here on in is be terrified of the
future.
And that's the price of waking up and
that's the end of paradise and that's
the beginning of history and that's how
that story goes.
In this sweat of thy face,
hell thou eat bread til thou return unto
the ground,
for out of it was taken for dust thou
art and unto Dust Thou shall return.
And Adam called his wife's name Eve
because she was the mother of all living
unto Adam also and unto his wife did the
Lord God make coats of skin and clothed
them.
Hunted William Blake by the way,
and the Lord.
God said,
behold,
the man is become as one of us to know
good and evil,
and now lest he put forth his hand and
take also of the tree of life and eat
and live forever.
I'll go over this again next week.
Therefore,
the Lord God sent him from the fourth,
fourth,
from the garden of Eden to till the
ground from whence he was taken.
So he drove out the man and he placed at
the east of the garden of Eden Cherubims
and a flaming sword which turned every
way to keep the way of the tree of life.
One more thing and then we'll stop.
So I thought,
why in the world?
So Adam and eve are tempted by the
snake.
They eat the fruit,
they wake up,
they realized they're naked.
They realize that they're vulnerable.
They realized the future.
They realized they're gonna die.
They realized that they have to work.
It counts for difficulty in conception
and the fall of humankind from
unconscious paradise.
Okay,
that makes sense.
What about the knowledge of good and
evil?
What in
the world does that mean?
The mesopotamians believed that human
beings were made out of the blood of
king,
knew who was the worst monster that
time,
Matt,
who was the goddess of chaos,
could imagine and then produce.
So their idea was that whatever it was
about humanity,
there was something deeply,
deeply,
deeply demonically flawed.
So that's their conception and the sound
of that same value that these stories
emerge.
So what is opening your eyes and
realizing your vulnerability have to do
with the knowledge of good and evil.
And really I thought about that.
I really thought about that.
I got to tell you,
I thought about that for like 20 years
because I knew there was something there
that I could not put together.
And at the same time I was,
I was reading things.
I'm going to tell you something truly
awful.
And so if you need a trigger warning,
you're,
you're getting one.
And believe me,
I do not give trigger warnings lately.
So I'm going to tell you something he
will never forget.
So this is what unit seven,
31 used to do in China.
And China is a Japanese unit.
During the Second World War,
right,
and as far as I can tell,
they did the most horrific things that
were done to anyone during World War II
and that's really something,
so this is what they did.
They took their prisoners and they would
put them in a position so that their
arms would freeze solid and then they
would take them outside and pour hot
water over their arms and then he would
repeat that until the flesh came off the
bones and they were doing that to
investigate the treatment of frostbite
for soldiers.
Or you can look up unit seven,
31 if you want to have nightmares.
So that's a unit seven slash 31.
That's human beings.
Someone thought that up and then people
did it.
That's knowledge of good and evil.
Here's the,
here's the key,
man.
You know you're vulnerable.
No other animal knows that you know what
hurts you because you're vulnerable and
now that you know what hurts you,
you can figure out what hurts someone
else.
And as soon as you know what hurts
someone else and you can use that,
you have the knowledge of good and evil,
well,
it's a pretty good trick that the snake
pose because it doesn't look like it's
exactly the sort of thing that we might
have wanted if we would've known what
the consequence was.
But as soon as a human being as self
conscious and aware of his own
nakedness,
that he has the capacity for evil and
that is introduced into the world right
at that point.
And here's the rest of the story.
So there's the snake,
right in your some tree dwelling primate
in the snake eats you.
And that sucks.
So let's like,
let's watch out for the damn snakes.
And then you think,
well wait a minute,
your brain grows and you think,
wait a minute.
Well,
there's not just snake.
There's were snakes live.
Why don't we just get the hell out of
the tree and go hunt down the snakes and
get rid of them.
So those are sort of like potential
snakes.
And so the snake becomes potential
snake.
And it's the same circuit that you're
using to do this thinking and then you
get rid of the damn snakes.
It's like St Patrick chases the mode of
Ireland.
No more snakes.
Everything's paradise.
It's like,
no,
that's not.
That's not how it works.
No.
Well,
now you've got the human snakes.
You're a tribe.
You've got tribal enemies.
You've got to defend yourself against
the human snakes,
right?
So maybe your empire experience and you
get rid of all the human snakes.
And then what happens?
Well,
they start to grow,
develop inside.
It's like you get rid of all the
external enemies and you make a big city
and all of a sudden there's enemies that
pop up inside because the snake isn't
just the snake in the garden.
And this snake isn't just the possible
snake.
And the snake isn't just the snake.
That's your enemy.
The snake is your friend,
right?
Because your friend can be true.
And then it's even worse than that
because you can be true to you.
And so even if you get rid of all the
outside snakes,
you've got an inside snake and God only
knows what it's up to.
And that's why the bloody Christians
associated the snake in the garden of
Eden with Satan,
it's unbelievably brilliant because you
got to think what's the enemy?
Well,
the snake fair enough,
but you know,
that's good if you're a tree dwelling
primate.
But if you're a sophisticated human
being,
you know,
with 6 million years of additional
evolution and you're really trying to
solve the problem of what it is,
that's the great enemy of mankind.
Well,
it's the human propensity for evil,
right?
As such,
well,
that's the figure of Satan.
That's what that figure means.
Just like there's a logo,
that's the truth,
that speaks order out of chaos at the
beginning of time.
There's an antithetical spirit,
the hostile brother that's cane to able,
which we'll talk to talk about next
week,
that's doing exactly the opposite.
It's motivated by absolutely nothing but
malevolence and the willingness to
destroy and it has every reason for
doing so.
And that's
what's revealed in the next story.
And cain and Abel in one paragraph,
the first glimmerings of that outside of
the strange insistence by the Christian
mystics,
let's say,
on the identity between the snake in the
garden of Eden and the author of all
evil himself.
Thank you.
Okay,
so we only have 15 minutes today.
I wanted to finish that.
So apologies for going over a little
longer and.
All right.
Hi Dr Peterson over the last couple of
weeks and further back,
you talk a lot about consciousness and
the importance of it and I was hoping to
get your opinion on an issue of
consciousness that has often seen
Christianity among other groups and
politics kind of clashed.
So I'm hoping to get your views on the
consciousness or lack thereof of human
fetus
and how that's impacted your views on
abortion whenever they are and any
legislation.
Thank you.
Okay,
so the first question is,
do I have an answer for that?
That's a good enough answer to actually
reveal.
No,
I don't,
but I'll.
I can flail about a little bit around
it.
Abortion is clearly wrong.
Don't think anybody debates that.
You wouldn't recommend that someone that
you love have one.
Okay.
Now,
having clarified that that mere
statement doesn't eliminate the
complexity of the situation.
The first question is,
is should everything wrong be illegal?
That's a tough question.
Everything that's wrong isn't illegal.
Then there's the additional complication
of the difference,
let's say in gravity regarding the
problem in relationship to men and women
and we don't know how to deal with that.
Having said that,
I would say that it's actually the wrong
question.
There's something Leonard Cohen said
once he said that in a massacre,
there's no decent place to stand,
and what he meant by that was sometimes
you're aware there is no good decision
left,
no matter what you do.
It's wrong.
So then the question is,
how did you get there?
Well,
let's say you're in a position where you
are inclined to seek an abortion.
The question is,
how did you get there?
Now we have a lot to straighten out
about sexual relationships between men
and women.
In the modern world,
they're bent and warped and demented out
of shape.
One of the things I see with young
people,
for example,
is that they will engage in sexual acts
with one another that they would not
talk about with one another.
I mean,
couples will do that for that matter,
like married couples will do that,
but they're married.
That's a different story.
It seems to me that if you are willing
to engage in a sexual act with someone
with whom you would not discuss that
act,
you probably put the cart before the
horse,
so the discussion regarding the legality
of abortion is nested inside a larger
discussion about the morality of
abortion and that's nested inside a
larger discussion about the proper place
of sexuality and human behavior and to
me that's the level at which the problem
needs to addressed.
Now I don't have the answer to that,
you know,
because they all answer was get married
now.
It's a good answer and it's an answer
that people should still listen to,
but we'll put that aside momentarily.
I had a client at one point who was.
I don't know.
She was probably.
No,
I'm going to disguise her in a variety
of different ways.
She was 27,
28,
thereabouts,
had come from a relatively conservative
background,
quite a timid or fearful person and also
not very well,
not sophisticated in relationship to
relationships and she'd never had sex.
Well,
there's a bunch of things she'd never
done.
Well,
the answer from me to her wasn't
continued to be timid about everything
because that wasn't working out for her.
She needed to go have some adventures.
Now,
sexual adventures like other adventures
are dangerous and so you have to be very
careful when you encourage people to go
out and have adventures,
but,
but too much.
Timidity and caution also constitutes a
pathway to perdition.
Let's say you can't just say to people
in the morning world while you know,
sex till you're married,
unless you're going to get married when
you're very young and perhaps you
should.
I don't know about that,
but I don't think that we're mature
enough as a culture to have a serious
discussion about sexual impropriety,
especially in the aftermath of the birth
control pill.
And we seriously need to do that and we
haven't.
And so I think the eternal debate about
abortion,
horrible as it is,
is a,
it's the surface manifestation of a much
deeper problem.
Now,
I talked a little bit today about the
utility of marriage,
like the spiritual utility of marriage,
and that's something that I think we're
so immaturely cynical as a culture,
like we don't.
We're not wise enough to look at an
institution like marriage and to really
think about what it means and what it
signifies.
It signifies a place that people can tie
the ropes of their lives together so
that they're stronger.
It signifies a place where people can
tell the truth to one another.
It signifies a place where sexuality can
properly be integrated into life.
That's no easy.
That's no easy task.
It's a place where children,
at least in principle,
it can be put first and foremost as they
should be once they exist.
And so there's a much broader discussion
that has to happen.
I think before any concentration on the
legality of abortion is labeled to get
anywhere at all.
That's what it looks like to me.
So that's the best I can do with that
question.
Thank you.
Hi,
Dr Peterson earlier you showed a picture
of and newer.
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
oh cyrus.
And in your maps of meaning lectures,
you also explained that cultures around
the world have these twin snakes that
are were everywhere,
man.
Yeah.
And so you mentioned that you believe
this is a representation of DNA.
You would bring that up to Jesus.
What is it with you guys tonight?
Yeah,
well,
yeah.
No,
I wouldn't say I believe that.
I have my suspicions that,
that might be it.
Yeah,
because believe is too strong a word,
but those representations are
everywhere.
And read this book.
This is a good one.
Oh Man.
Now I have to remember the book by an
anthropologist who went down to the
Amazon jungle and experimented
intensively with Iowasca.
I think it's called the cosmic serpent.
I think that's the name of the book.
You could read that.
There's another one called breaking open
the head,
which is also pretty damn interesting.
And there's something to those books.
I mean the cosmic serpent kind of goes
off on a bit of a tangent I would say.
Although breaking open the head is,
it's better,
better,
it seems to stay more constrained and
tight,
but there's,
we don't know the limits of our
perception,
especially under certain conditions and
I think people have had intimations of
DNA as the cosmic serpent for ever,
so.
Yeah.
But that's like,
that's way out on the frontiers of
knowledge,
right?
Like I'm,
I'm guessing in a dreamlike way when I'm
making statements like that.
So because you didn't mention that you
did believe it and that there were sort
of maybe some,
some dreams and interpretations that
might have emerged,
but I don't see how we could have
perceived DNA as it is,
right?
Well,
yes we did.
We didn't objectively,
but I'm not so sure we didn't
subjectively and me,
it's very strange that these,
that these double helix is exist in so
many places in that they're are often
utilized as healing symbols with the
snake.
So anyways,
like I said,
that's.
What do you call that?
I'm a high.
It's not hypothesizing.
It's one thing worse than that.
Speculating.
Those are speculations.
I'm,
I'm operating at the edge of my
understanding,
but our perceptions are very mutable and
they can,
we can see things under some conditions
that you wouldn't think that anybody
could see.
So.
Okay.
Yep.
Thank you.
Um,
so I was just starting to have a thought
while you were talking about sort of
getting to the end of the talk about the
snake and the and the apple and so on.
So what you're saying is the moment
that,
that uh,
that Adam and eve eat the apple,
they become nervous or whatever.
So that's awareness of their own
vulnerability.
So then like you said,
it's also awareness of their own
capacity to do harm.
So it's like when they are eating the
apple then that's them.
Their immediate sort of a nervous
reaction is,
is because they ate the apple and they
kind of became evil in that moment or
something like that.
So when they woke up and because they,
they woke up and realized how they could
be hurt,
how they could and would be hurt over
the,
over the,
over the upcoming.
Over time.
It's the same as the discovery of you
did the discovery of your own nakedness
and the discovery of time are very,
very similar phenomena mean.
Sure.
As soon as you know how you can be hurt,
well you don't have to just consult your
evil fantasies.
It's like wild really hurt him.
Oh yeah.
That would work.
It's like,
how do you know that?
Well,
you just think about it.
What would happen if that happened to me
that would hurt.
Oh yeah,
that'll work.
It'll hurt him or her and you know,
you probably think that way twice a week
or maybe twice a day.
Jesus,
every time you have an argument with
someone,
Oh you have to do is look at the back of
your mind a little bit.
You don't want to,
that's for sure.
But if you do,
you'll see these sorts of thought
processes generating constantly.
It's like,
you know,
in a back and forth discussion,
particularly with people you love,
it's like you're always looking for a
place to put the knife in.
It seems really similar to.
Seems like they're kind of discovering
the kind of union shadow within
themselves.
So that,
that is the moment where it got
introduced into the human spirit.
Sure.
One of the things about the shadow is
that it's also when you integrate that,
that's what makes you a substantial
person.
Right?
So it's like,
it seems to me that on one hand,
well it's,
it seems like this tragedy that Satan
the most evil,
the father of evil,
whatever has introduced into people,
but it also seems like without that
shadow that people are kind of in
substantial.
So
yeah.
Well,
right,
right.
I mean,
like I said,
that there's been a multitude of
interpretations emerge as a consequence
of that story.
What was got up to was,
was God in fact evil,
the initial God,
like why?
Why would he create a snake?
Why would he put it in the garden?
Why would there be these trees?
What the hell is going on with the whole
Satan thing?
You know,
it's very,
very problematic.
Well,
we'll talk about it more.
And this again is,
let's call it speculation.
Well,
if you want to make something strong,
you test it.
And maybe if you want to make something
ultimately strong,
you tested ultimately,
and I think that there's an aspect of
being that has that element is that
human beings are tested to ultimately
it's partly because we know good and
good and evil now and so that's the
landscape in which we exist.
So you could say the landscape is across
it's chaos in order and as and evil and
we're stuck in the middle between those
two things.
It's a very common theme by the way,
in video games.
Exactly that chaos order,
good evil.
It's the.
It's the basic plot of endless video
games and that's perhaps because it's
the basic plot.
Those are the things we have to contend
with.
Well,
I had a vision once.
It shouldn't tell you this,
but I will.
Anyways.
I had a vision once that I went to
heaven and I was putting in a enrollment
amphitheater with Satan just like thor
in countering the hulk,
right?
That's coming up in that new avengers
movie.
And so that was rather a shock because I
thought that was a hell of a thing to
happen in heaven.
And so I had this battle and I won in a
day and I came up to God and said,
what's with the whole Roman amphitheater
thing there,
it seemed like a bit over the top to me,
said,
why would you put me in a ring with
someone thinking like that?
And he said,
because I knew you could win and you
know,
I don't know what to make of that one
thing I should make of it as,
I shouldn't tell you,
but whatever.
But you know,
there's something,
there's something to that in my
estimation.
It's like,
do you protect the people you love or do
you try to make them strong?
So you think it's that it's not that
heavily Satan to thank for making a
substantial.
It's that God gave us Satan in order to
make a substantial wall.
I'd hesitate to say that because you
know,
it's,
it's so cut and dried.
But I would say that,
that that's a strong underlying theme in
the biblical narrative.
Yes.
Now it's certainly not the only theme
and it's not the only interpretation by
any stretch of the imagination,
but there is something there.
There's something there,
you know,
at the end we didn't talk about this.
God puts up his flaming sword and these
chairmen to keep you away from the tree
of life.
It's like it seeing if if paradise and
immortality or the promised land and
why,
what's with the whole flaming angel and
sword thing?
We could have just had the damn fruit
5,000
years ago and not bothered with the
problem.
Well,
it seems to me that there's something
like,
I don't know what it is,
consciousness through tragedy,
clarity through suffering.
Maybe something like that or maybe the
perfection that lurks as a potential in
the future is something that has to be
earned rather than given.
Maybe it has no value without free
choice.
Maybe we have to distinguish between
good and evil.
Now that we have the capacity to
actually apprehend them.
Maybe that's what life is about.
Maybe that's the separating of the wheat
from the chaff.
See,
that's the idea and revelation,
right?
Because when Christ comes back in the
book of revelation,
he divides the amd from the saved and
the saved are the people who lived in
logos,
roughly speaking and the damned or those
who don't,
and so there's this idea that there's
this dynamic that underlies experience
that he is in fact that's sorting.
Now I don't know what to make of that at
all,
but that's the story,
but what I can make of that is that I.
I can't put a lever underneath the
argument that I just made tonight about
the relationship between the development
of vision,
the snake fruit,
nakedness time,
future work,
and most importantly,
the emergence of evil.
That seems to me to be.
I cannot find a way to undermine that
argument.
It seems I can't break it,
and that's what I'm always looking for
when I'm trying to formulate ideas.
I'm trying to look for something that no
matter how hard I try,
I cannot break and I can't break that
set of ideas.
Now what the full implication is of that
God only knows,
right?
But,
but I could say also practically,
you know,
one of the things that I've observed is
that lies and deception destroy people's
lives.
And when they start telling the truth
and acting it out,
things get a lot better.
GotTa stop.
Yeah.